you ready yeah
yeah all right hey what's going on it's
Bill Burr it's time for the Thursday
afternoon just before Friday Monday
Morning podcast and I'm just checking in
on you checking to see how your uh your
week is going and as always if you know
when I'm filming that means I have a
special guest and uh that I want to talk
to that is in town possibly coming
through because she's doing big time
Hollywood [__] out here the one and only
Rachel Feinstein thanks how are you who
will be at Helium Comedy Club in Philly
yes because that's a chain now in Philly
uh for New Year's Eve New Year's Eve
weekend New Year's Eve weekend what's
going on not much it's weird to be here
it's weird to see you I mean is it weird
to talk to me in this this controlled
environment after all these years I mean
I've known you since like what yeah 99
2000. yeah when we first met we were
like Neighbors on the Upper East Side
and um that's right drink at that dive
bar like Mug Shots we I was like yeah
you me Sharon the Upper East Side crew I
was like violently poor like me and
Sharad used to call our apartment
squalor because it was just so
unexpected we had a shower in the
kitchen and Sherrod would just bring
random girls through there and and there
was no there was no door on my bathroom
um or my bedroom rather they the girls
would have to walk through my bathroom
was Railroad and go and it wasn't there
it was a [__] Railroad and Tony and
Robert were just getting so much ass and
they thought it was hilarious that they
would have to parade the girls through
my room to use the bathroom whenever
they were getting laid and I'd have to
have these weird uncomfortable
conversations with some girl like
holding her t-shirt down
and like and I felt like Sherrod would
openly say this he'd be very pleased
probably that I was telling more people
about this but he he would use me as
like part of the oiling process with the
women because it'd be like look I have
this female roommate he's like yeah he's
like yes you're safe and I'm like I'm
telling them with their eyes and you're
not you're making a terrible decision
but sure I was like yeah no it was
helpful right he's like that's how I got
my goods flowing I was like I'm just I
was part of the lotioning up like look
there's a woman here it's got to be a
good idea you're lucky the FBI didn't
come in because he would have taken off
and you would end up having a you know
they do that in those boiler rooms it's
always like the low person on the totem
pole those were such fun days though I
remember uh we had a lot of fun we were
so poor but I was having so much fun I I
that was I was sleeping on the uh the
futon and mine was actually a studio
apartment that they slammed a wall into
yeah and called it a one bedroom and I
was like I have a one bedroom apartment
no to me you were rich I was like I know
a successful person and then I I met the
chick upstairs who had the exact same
unit above me and his words are just
like this giant Studio
and uh I I never even brought it up
to my landlord or anything I was just I
I knew oh that they sold it as a as a as
a one bedroom I could have complained
and gone to the board and done all of
that but I was just like dude I really
want to waste it's like all right I've
never gone to anybody who has time for a
board yeah I did it one time really yeah
against the taxi driver what happened
what was the situation
um
we got into it on the uh the FDR
trying to [__] who was gonna go and I
ended up winning who was going to go
next you know those New York battles
with the car yeah so he was [__] I
could see him yelling at me and [__] and
I was being you know I was being a dick
so I was just sort of like are you
enjoying it he's beeping the horn and
everything and I was just waving and
everything and then when he drove by me
he took like he had a handful of chains
this point we'd finally got on the FBR
we're doing like 50 and it was raining
out yeah and he [__] took his hand
full of change and he just was [__]
throwing it at the side of my car he did
it like three times he had just changed
this is the night like the 2000s so
change stuff from their car I just was
just throwing it it was like okay on
this side and I'm like you [__]
[__] he did it again
and he was such a dick and I was so mad
I was like all right [__] this guy and I
got his number and I actually complained
and then we showed up
it was so funny because we showed up for
the hearing and by then I wasn't even
mad anymore and he showed up with a
lawyer I remember when he's this Asian
guy and he tried to make it racist
really well first of all he admitted
that he threw the change at me yeah and
so I was like why the [__] would he do
that why would he admit well first of
all he had a lawyer it was him his
lawyer and me sitting talking to this
guy in a desk that was like half the
size of this in this little room
and we would just saying there's nothing
Dumber the two men mediating after they
had a stupid [__] it was really bad
it was really I ended up feeling really
bad so
he admitted that he threw the change at
my car but he said he goes ah he goes I
did it because I look over and he he
would he was looking at me he was going
like this what he said I don't know why
he he was totally called you a hack and
I was just like so I was just like
you're telling me I was driving 50 miles
an hour in the rain and I took my hands
off doing that and then that's when the
lawyer jumped in he goes I think we have
here there's a couple people that got a
little upset
and the guy he ended up getting
suspended for like a week there is and
then I felt bad I just wanted him to I
don't know why I see one of the few
vindictive things I've ever done and I
felt bad and this is the [__] funny
thing is I [__] got a cab like a
month later and I swear to God I think
it was him and I got in the cab and I
saw the picture and I heard his voice I
don't [__] know right and so I just
sat directly behind him and I was just
sitting there like that I was I tipped
him well in case it was him
all right there you go I've had that
happen before getting back in a cab
where I've had like a weird moment it
probably was him I had that one time
because it was this crazy white dude who
his claim to fame was he auditioned for
like Metallica or something and he was
one of those guys he had like Surfer
energy that was going on he told you the
whole story they do that here that's why
I can't take the Ubers here they just
tell you their whole yeah their ban
everything
um they play things for me somebody
plays something for me on the way over
he was like playing me his tracks and
stuff I'm like you're networking with me
I don't want to blame the victim here
but how does the conversation get that
deep don't you just put some headphones
on sorry I have to take a call no this
happens actually with to me all the time
that's very fair yeah people just tell
me things and then they'll start like
weeping and stuff they're like I've
never told anyone this before but I
definitely something's happening with me
that I pull up because that would not
happen with Billy like you would nobody
would start to no people do not open up
to me no I've like gently held people I
don't know very well I held a woman at
like a CVS I don't know people just
start like we like [__] about their
lives they'll be like it happens every
time somebody opens for me they're like
ah shut up wait what happens they just
don't walk up to you what happens before
um there's something you're doing you're
too friendly I think I do you know I
think it's some of it's probably for my
mom because my mother like she loves
like dark information like she wants to
get to the bot like she listens with
like a leg up like that you know and
just kind of jazzes out she loves to get
to like the we call it pain chambering
because my mom likes to take somebody
and like get to their pain and I feel
like I have I'm like a little more fun
about it but she's acting like she's
helping but she's just into the gossip
yeah I think she's somewhere in between
somewhere in between she's she was a
therapist and with like No Boundaries
and would tell me the darkest weirdest
information about everybody her patience
like she was really going rogue like I
would she would pick me up when she
picked me up she's done practicing right
not not now so I can't she's retired
thank you okay no she would pick me up
from a play date and just tell me the
weirdest [__] about like the parents I
was way too young should be like did I
tell you that
assaulted early on in the marriage and
then it ruined their sex life because
there never felt he could protect her
I'm like I'm like I'm in the sixth grade
she would tell me the weirdest [__] what
age did you finally just say like Mom
why are you telling me this [__] I told
her I've I've confronted her like later
on because like I'll I did a bit about
it like about how the weirdest [__] she
would tell me and I want the leg up is
[__] hilarious this is how she
listens just
and it's really funny watching her and
my husband because he's like a repressed
Catholic fireman and I'm like oh you
can't pain chamber him like you're not
gonna catch a wave with Pete like he's
he's closed like a box you know what I
mean and my mom tries to Jazz in there
she wants to know about like fire trauma
she does like a shimmy when he starts
talking about that kind of [__] but she
can't get through but like I told her a
story I mean she saw me tell a story
about how she used to do that on stage
once and she's like I didn't do that if
you want to put in your talents show
skit or whatever but I was like yes you
did and I like how else would I have
known that was raped and that her
husband couldn't protect her and then it
ruined their sex life she's like well
you got me there
I'm like that dude I have this cough
that the only time it happens is when I
laugh so this is going to be difficult
here I have to edit this out oh also I
have to say about the change I throw
change I think throwing change is very
funny and I have thrown I used to throw
a change on the sky after we would
ex-boyfriend of mine after we would have
sex because it's just a funny thing to
throw change and I dated a guy once the
go get yourself something nice I just
feel like you're disgusting what
happened right here is disgusting but I
just throw some nickels on it
one time we
've caught me Gathering the change and
get it ready like we were about to hook
up and I was prepping the change like
ahead of time so the sex is really a
setup for the punch yes
well it's funny I was like I knew it
would be funny after so I was like I
brought the change bedside but I just
tossed it on him and I'd be like you're
disgusting now go out and buy yourself
something special and just sort of give
them like a soft slow face right
when I do that to my husband he gets
terrified I'll give him just a soft soft
like this is a guy that like runs into
act burning buildings when I go like
that to him he shudders like shakes like
a [__]
you shut up all right don't feel sad or
feeling or I'll try to replay I'll be
like let's talk about some of the things
that happened
so
let's process should we go through the
earlier Beats
you're bringing my [__] cough back
here all right
Andrew is this going to be a problem or
what sorry
um let me ask you so do you so that's
basically you're just doing your mom
I sort of am except I feel like with me
I think my mom is look I'm not saying
that I'm not a cocktail of problems
myself but my mom's just like a heavier
person that's probably why I'm a
comedian because she would just like
lock me in these dark weird stories you
know what I mean but I think I have I
feel like when people open up to me like
my dad would do the same thing would he
do that too he he would like talk about
all this trauma at the [__] hospital
and it was his way of getting us him
getting him out of taking us to do stuff
where he would just whatever you wanted
to do is ah you know I had a patient the
other day you know they went out to
McDonald's
and uh you know there was a train track
there and he lost his leg let out
it's so funny your dad painted there's
nothing he can do nothing you can do
about it's like you can just say I'm
tired I don't want to bring you like
anything that you I don't want to take
you to the Dieter where would you want
to go that you would get out of it was
usually like toys or something that you
wanted to get like uh I mean a lot of it
you know there was a lot of lawn darts
bow and arrows and four three wheelers
back then where kids were actually dying
on
so
um
you know he heard that and he's all of
those stories so he heard them second
hand I mean he wasn't working on stuff
like that he was all natural facial and
prosthodontist [__] yeah my mom will
take anything she can get it could be
three times removed from the family I'm
like why the [__] am I hearing about any
of this and it's it's she'll be like
she'll start with a certain tone in her
voice she'll be like
did you hear you know and I'm just like
oh Christ and she'll be like
yeah I think you went to he she tries to
lock you with her eyes she does this
weird thing I love the names yeah
you went to Hebrews go make doesn't ring
about it's never positive she's never
like oh well he's getting a lot of [__]
and he went to Harvard no she's like
he's got
he's like he's got coven 19. she always
says the 19. I'm like no one says the 19
anymore except my mom I'm like and if
you try to God forbid imply just gently
that someone might be okay I'm like well
I'm sure he's vaccinated mom I think
he'll be all right I don't think so you
know he's immunocompromised she gets mad
I still say Sears in Roebuck yes oh
she's coveted 19 Sears and Roebuck
trying to think of something else that
somebody got bought out I don't even
think Sears is even around anymore
no that's you know what that's where I'm
at that age now where it just there's
all of this stuff closing and I drive
down the street like oh
no like I just drove down
I know people that do feel I do it
bothers me it bothers me if it's a place
that I like uh to be then just you know
another stupid Glass Tower or some
[__] Starbucks yeah because there was
this guy had this random business on La
Brea out here where he just bought these
signs from defunct businesses in this
crazy [__] yeah some of them were huge
and just all of this random stuff that
like you know somebody would buy and put
in their house or maybe put it in like
their man cave or whatever it was
obviously a very Niche business on an
expensive Street in La so it's days were
numbered and I drove by it just
yesterday I was on my way down to the
[__] 10 or something like that and I
drove by and I audibly by myself
I went like oh they knocked that place
down
what would they do you know that one
yeah there's a lot of movie props and
stuff yeah movie props and stuff it had
all this really really cool [__] where
you just
he basically had all that [__] where you
you know but the third time you moved
you're like why did I buy this big
stupid [__] sign it's um Caroline's
closing we were talking about that I
mean we got to give a shout out to that
like
that [__] place closing that's like
the biggest one to close since the
Boston when the Boston Comedy Club
closed I was like oh my God that was the
first like real
um show that I did like where I was
actually you know paid for comedy we
used to these bringer shows we had to
bring you know 25 people uh to perform I
didn't even have friends really in New
York at that point I had like seven
friends you were one of them I would
just go to this local bar and try to beg
people to come to my show I felt
terrible I remember this one guy would
always come he was like morbidly obese
he played pool and I was like he would
all Rufus would always make it down to
my dumb bringer show you know what I
mean and I had to bring Rufus The Morbid
obese morbidly opening pool player and
he would just make it down he'd be like
all right baby I like to laugh foreign
but it's funny that it's funny because
like we'd had to do so many insane and I
would they didn't have bringer shows
when I came up you just performed in
front of two people and then finally you
know which is worse Lewis Shaffer
started barking yeah down in the village
and then that changed and you know
probably saved a few clubs people
started barking and handing out flyers
and then I think they kind of got that
uh from the band thing you know we have
like the pay to play yes type of [__]
um it's funny that you say that about
businesses too and old businesses
because I was just having a discussion
about this because like people like get
really sad when something closes and I'm
like I I feel TR I feel bad because I
think it's so funny like why could you
give a [__] if like he's when he used to
drink he would like like get real
emotional about like Jimmy's tire shop
you know Brooklyn's different now and
like it was a disgusting place it's good
it's gone it's something else is in its
place I felt bad that I didn't feel like
you know like some sort of empathy for
it but I was like asking my therapist
about it I'm like why do I I feel bad
but I only think it's funny that he
talks about like old churches being gone
when he's drunk like who gives a [__]
but that is funny
I wouldn't question it I understand both
sides of that
if I if I was going okay knock down the
street
s enjoy that because I would think uh
you know she took me from feeling sad to
laughing you know what I think I just
don't understand like I don't understand
having Nostalgia for buildings I get
like certain a time or something but not
like a small local business I mean when
I say he used to like I mean firemen are
all like this like get drunk and just
yell about the founding fathers or some
weird horseshit that's obviously all the
other like active trauma that they're
not dealing with but he would like
instead of like dealing with it somebody
dying on the job he'd be like oh
chippy's tire shop and I'm like come on
I can't I can't play the woman that
listens and soothes you because Jimmy's
tire shop is gone I'm actually on I'm
actually starting to think
because I do this a lot now it just
[__] happens you just become that old
guy going like ah you know it's great
1991.
and I'm now thinking back
really trying to like remember it
going was it that great or was it just
that I was young
and I had my whole life ahead of me I
think like there'll be people who
romanticize the pandemic from this
generation yeah you know you know what a
touch ought to be tough and you had to
make a stand either I am wearing a mask
or I'm not yeah yeah unlike these
[__] kids today with their robots
that's what it's going to end up being
but like yeah you're right I kind of uh
meanwhile we just were bored inside and
like staring at our phones it wasn't
like there was this you know Pro you
know what I mean like it was like I did
like life before phones yeah I did like
uh but it's it's been this great thing
where like I mean the level of uh you
know I called up Louis faranda you know
I mean that was one of the big phone
calls I got in my my career was he
called me up uh I sent him a VHS tape
that this guy Gary Marino shot me at the
[__]
uh Grill 93 in Andover yeah Andover
Andover Andover message I remember all
of that that was one of those things
part of my motor and I sent it to
Caroline's and I came home and on my
answering machine yeah it was you know
just listen it was just like hey Bill
this is uh Louis faranda from uh
Caroline's I listened to it a thousand
times I just watched your tape
um you're very funny
I'd like you to come down and uh maybe
do a spot and I was just dude I was
jumping up and down in my railroad
apartment in my living room area which
was pretty big actually I could get a
couch in there and everything I was
[__] jumping up and down I couldn't
believe it I just kept playing it over
and over again and uh
and just the thought of like I'm gonna
do a spot and how did you go how did it
go yeah Caroline's was like there was
like a buzz behind that name Caroline's
was like show business itself yeah I
don't think that he even gave me a spot
when I really think it wasn't until like
a while later yeah but that tracks it
was just basically letting me know that
I was on his radar but that was still
[__] huge that this guy knew who I
was so because that was a place like you
couldn't really hang out because it was
like like this star business Crown Jewel
thing but like so I called him yesterday
and he was you know you know talking
about you know you know like basically
quadrupled their their rent or something
like that and um and then also the
business changing turning you know you
know the roast battle stuff the [__]
uh um podcasting and then young Comics
today like to me like the the like the
thing was like Someday I'm gonna
headline Caroline yeah yeah but now they
see because of this [__] ridiculous
boom we're in I know they see like I'm
gonna play a theater in like Arenas and
all of that type of [__] so it's like
which to me like I get it because that's
what they're seeing but just from where
I was once again doing the old thing ah
when I was a kid you wanted to play the
funny bones
and go clean for the weekend and make a
bonus I also think like also I feel like
men once they start to be in their 40s
they start to they just they excrete
some kind of emotion after that but they
don't know how to do it or articulate it
so it just gets funneled through these
strange avenues like my dad used to weep
about like baseball baseball never shed
a tear at my own wedding but like he
cried at the Baseball Hall of Fame every
year just like wailing you couldn't
connect to his own children but then he
would just have tears no that's why I
always liked you because I always
thought it was you would sit back and
watch men's behavior and just ridiculous
dude she used to just [__]
trash us and then you would trash women
too like can you do that character the
one who's enamored with the uh the
bartender at our local places one of my
favorite things every time we'd get
hammered we'd get like three four drinks
and I'd be like Rich right through the
girl enamored I can't even remember I
mean the girl you'd be like why the
bartender
well the bartender is the star of the
bar
well he said he's gonna put
he said he was going to insert himself
inside me and put me in the pictures he
said all I had to do is sit naked on his
lap for half an hour
I totally forgot about the bartender
because you always go funny the surplus
of [__] that bartenders got I always
wanted to be like the Robin Hood of ass
and take it away from the bartenders and
give it to the scientists the people
that deserve the app and it's just a
silly it's just this ridiculous thing
that they get to do that pause you'd be
like the bartender why why he's the he's
he's the star of the bar you know he
looked at me at my cans too maybe this
will be the night
I suppose it was coming I knew it he'd
look down here before
I don't know so ridiculous so
is there any way you can cut some of
these coughs out
um I'm sure they could cut the coughs
out yeah cut the coffee Jesus Christ cut
the goddamn coughs out so um
yeah so that was basically the beginning
of all of us uh hanging out so now that
we're living on different coasts we're
married we got kids and [__] uh how we
basically stay in touch which is funny
to me because I forgot you your mom was
a therapist is basically what me and
Rachel do to stay in touch is we just
send these ridiculous self-help videos
that are just complete horseshit on
Instagram that everybody's like going
like this I'm like oh my God that's me
you know the ones where they go like uh
you know uh what's that [__] stupid
one where it's just like um
that when you sent the other day where
it's just like you know strong people uh
it's always some weird riddle like oh
that was drunk people so strong people
don't need anyone a strong person it's
always excuse you and then then all
these [__] morons are going like yes
the horseshit that gets circulated
online
infuriates me it'll just be like and
it's always so like weird and fear-based
it was like a woman the video was just
like a woman alone in her bed and it was
just like clearly it looked like she was
being watched it was like very haunting
the way the videos Calvin Klein yeah
Calvin Klein yeah it was just like she
was sitting there like reading in bed
yeah her top was falling off a little it
was very uncomfortable it felt like it
was definitely like an assault a rapist
point of view towards their life I feel
like yeah it was rapist footage that
somebody then put a voice over it was
like repurposed for like some sort of
empowering horses let's let's we
actually brought a couple of these clips
here just this is I don't know how much
of this we're going to use but this is
just [__] that we send to each other all
right here's a guy basically telling you
uh this is like this guy's giving you a
life fingers already infuriate me dumb
[__] what you put your fingers I told
my wife when I got with her I said look
I'll do anything for you except one
thing
I will not give up on that drink if I
got to surrender my dream I'd rather be
alone
because if I abandon my dream I'll
abandon you I truly believe that I see
so many people man they give up their
dream for the wife they give up their
drink for the husband they give up their
and then and then the wife and the
husband get together and they have kids
and they give up their dream again
because of the kids and I said today we
have kids we cannot blame the kids for
not going after our potential and our
dreams if I got to be less than who I'm
meant to I love this guy
can't give you that all right that's
powerful that is going to be the dumbest
[__] and I just love the [__] who who
scored that
it's a [__] Trump it's so [__]
dramatic it's like am I watching the end
of private Saving Private Ryan and the
credits are rolling
I don't care can you imagine sitting in
like a [__] TGI Fridays across from
that guy going like
I will not give up my dream it's like
who the [__] asks you to give up your
dreams that's true this poor [__] just
try to have dinner and drink and you're
[__] babbling about this courtship
can you imagine about at first date how
exhausting he is just really setting out
the rules she's like he's like you
should be trying to get laid instead
he's just like here's what happens we
get married I don't give up my dream
she's like can I have some salmon and
like a compliment I give up my dream I'm
gonna give up on you
anyone like that that presets like a
just a series of ludicrous rules is he
can't let anything natural occur to him
obviously nothing and basically what
he's doing is he's he's setting somebody
up to be totally subservient yeah to him
because he's laying it on the line the
beginning which is a smart move if
that's how he wants to live because he's
going to get he doesn't want somebody
giving like some pushback right and
that's his thing so then it all gonna
it's all gonna fit underneath like that
category of like can you take the trash
out tonight I can't I'm working on my
dream and if I take that trash out I
might as well put my dreams in that
Barrel that's powerful there is nothing
well then the Comets are the best
everybody's just like what do they say
other what that's what it makes us
angriest is the people there the heart
here we go like this is [__] amazing
like how do you not look at this guy I
just want to put him down like a dog
like look at his dumb he needs to give
it he needs to be given a nice Swift
smack unless unless he knows he's just
commercial fishing with stupid
he thinks he's on to things look at his
look at how he sits of course he
believes in his dumb [__] can you
find that clip that the uh can you
imagine how exhausting a first date
would be on a man like that because he
know he's never listened for a moment in
his life he's just like listen all right
sugar tits here's how I work all right
first comes my dreams
and then comes I picked the side of the
bed
if I have to compromise on any of that
I told my wife this relationship is not
gonna work
it's like any of this on our first day
just make out with her why would you
give up on your dream and why would if
you gave up in your dream why would you
blame another person
and because you so [__] hate that you
gave up on your dream you're gonna blame
her and walk out on her
I didn't have the false to go after what
I wanted and it's because of you I don't
believe anyone that says that somebody
sat them down and told them to give up
on their dreams there's always people
are always talking about that like
hip-hop videos and stuff like that this
one teacher told me I could never amount
to somebody who's that is a Jay-Z lyric
no she didn't no teacher takes a child
aside and is like you're never gonna be
any I don't believe you oh yeah that's
like that it might have been slightly
dismissive but that's it at best right
yeah I also like when they're uh well I
mean one time my I had a math teacher go
for the next one we're gonna call in the
dumbest kid in the room Bill Burr but I
knew what he was doing wait a second
what I knew what he was doing though
what was he doing he was basically being
like you're not [__] working up to
your [__] potential but you're you're
a [__] grade point average I was the
dumbest kid in the world I can't believe
this was said to you and this is only
coming out at this point it was [__]
funny you enjoyed it I had those I had
other [__] that happened oh my God was
it a public school do you remember one
time I had Isis please I I gotta I gotta
talk around this I had a teacher that
was a trainer on a certain in a certain
sport
and uh I I was being an [__] in class
so I had to stay off to school but he
had to handle the sports thing so he
locked me in the trainer's room
with the lights off for the entire
[__] practice
oh my God I forgot to fight dumbass I
could have been a second I walked out
and said listen I won an a for the year
or I'm gonna tell the fire hazard I
could have burned it done I actually
thought it was funny I thought it was
funny Billy it would be such a
psychopath that you would be in there
getting a good laugh I gotta be honest
with you it didn't even remotely bother
me now I realize why we never used to go
to diners he would have to be against
the wall I just knew because every comic
we're all haunted in some way you're
gonna be we're all not okay we're all
just like you know but you used to
always have to be backed up against a
wall he's like I can see the [__]
door this wild look nice I don't even
remember being there like an upper east
side diner like who's coming through
it's like old ladies buying muffins but
that's probably because you were locked
in that goddamn room no it probably
wasn't because that was probably because
they get [__] hit enough times with
the actually it was just basically oh my
god the traffic if the traffic was
flowing in like that was the thing with
older kids
was if there was a younger kid with his
back tomb you'd come up or you just
[__] slap him in the head and it made
you it made you teeth go like that and
it [__] it made you mad was that like
a regular Boston that you I feel like
you grew up like Harry was a Boston
thing I just think it was and I wasn't
lived in the suburbs anyways it was just
a uh
it was it was just it was a thing that
older kids older older kids beat up
younger kids yeah because it was there
was no internet that is the best
sentence I've ever heard no because I
noticed when I was in in um New York
City I was on the subway and it was
totally chill but for now and I heard
it's kind of nuts and I was just looking
and everybody is [__] looking at
their phones which is brilliant because
back in the day you could only read the
advertising for so long before you met
somebody's eyes and they're like what
the [__] are you looking at and then all
you had a situation so
did you fight would you fight
I fought him to a sir I fought up until
about like Junior High and then
everybody else hit puberty I hit puberty
late and then all of a sudden I was like
six inches and about 30 pounds lighter
than everybody else and you know I you
know my fight record was pretty good up
through fifth grade and it just you know
like the old days I needed Peds to
[__] hang in there and I just would
you talk some [__] would you like start
stuff or would you I was both yeah I was
both bullied and I bullied kids what did
you say when you bullied I would do
anything to just watch I would watch us
I would watch that streaming of just the
[__] I mean you're talking this like 40
years ago I don't remember what you
would say this kid's face
you [__] idiot yeah just that [__]
you know it's such a true comment like
your face it was just that your face
bugs me yeah it's such a true Comics
thing to have a teacher say that you are
just stupid just tell you you're the
street and just you to get a nice solid
laugh out of that because I knew what he
was doing you knew it I know what he
said what's going on I know what he's
saying I know I know I'm not the dumbest
kid in the room but I also know I got an
eight I literally got an eight I
remember there was another guy there was
three of us this one year and it was
just like we would hold up our test like
cracking up laughing and try to you know
success all we could do we all ended up
in summer school that was uh
I think I got an eight in on a test and
I tried and I actually got extra help
I was like that it was just it was
because you're bored you weren't you
were not interested in it
it was algebra two Intrigue it was the
train was just so down the track and
over the [__] Hill there was no way
to even like I'll tell you one thing one
of the most [__] out of body
experiences I ever had was geometry like
I had no [__] I was like what is this
where did the numbers go so on ludicrous
opposite angles are congruent you're
like opposite angles would go growing I
I don't even know what it meant what it
was for and it wasn't until years later
it was just like oh they use this [__]
to make a bridge now it's finally
Tethered to something all of a sudden to
something we went [__] hilarious we
went from like numbers yeah for the
first eight grades and then ninth grade
all of a sudden they start throwing the
alphabet in but there was still enough
numbers so it's like all right we're at
a bigger school there's some new kids
here a b and c
right and Little Numbers squared and
then when we went into like geometry the
numbers were gone and there was just
shapes like we were in [__]
kindergarten like oh it's a triangle but
then there was this whole theory that
you had to memorize about these
triangles and circles and no the
protractors all of it I was such an
emergency [__] in school but especially
math like they couldn't beat the
information to my head just wouldn't
take it I had a tutor for a while who um
I later found out molested several other
girls didn't molest me and I do believe
it was because I was so dumb in math and
I infuriated him I think my own
stupidity like saved me because I was a
guy his name was my students are always
women his name was Mr file too he was no
it wasn't yes I swear to God his name
was Mr file he was a pedophile and
because I was so goddamn dumb and I
exhausted him I think he had no sexual
desire for me I still remember him being
like we're not even into the hard part
yet I'm just explaining the first thing
we gotta get to the hard part where I
get hard and then this thing happens
he used to be like come on this isn't
this is the beginning of the word
problem you can't already you actually
took him out of his pedophilia into just
like I like that he actually still
wanted to do his job before he ruined
your life
started with me I remember just him
being just so like [__] he was real
stressed at the end of The Cellar that
night when we were all telling getting
molested and lightly molested full-on
molested stories down at the cellar oh
my God it was one of the great nights
one of the most cathartic laughs I do
remember that Bobby Kelly or somebody
maybe it was Bobby somebody was like I
think again it was a lighter molestation
and here's what dirtbags all the comics
are and so hilarious
um this is how sick we all are somebody
had they all use like you know fake
names at the seller sometimes the people
that are you know more well known and
they don't want people knowing they're
on the lineup so is somebody used for
their fake name for the name of the
stepfather that molested this comedian
because he thought it was so funny that
Millet said Bobby and they used that as
their fake name on the lineup just for a
laugh that's what degenerate sociopaths
comedians are and it was hilarious and
and he laughed too they all thought it
was hysterical what else are you gonna
do yeah like how long can you cry about
about it and be like I wonder what I
would have been I mean that's how we
deal with [__] yeah you have to laugh I
mean yeah I remember I did this gig long
time ago with I think I told you this
was like me and Keith Robinson and my
dad's a civil rights lawyer a little Kev
was there too and they were just
trashing and trashing my we don't need
your dad's help dummy to lean on me to
leave us alone just trashing my dad's
occupation he was like a federal
prosecutor prosecuted all these Clans
cases like ah he bugs me tell him to
[__] stay out of my business
and at one point Keith goes I'm going to
call up your dad he goes he goes I want
to rape Rachel and I'm going to have a
dad defend me
he's I'm gonna call him up and I'm going
to say Mr Feinstein this is the case
that's going to make you a star
Ball but it's so but it's just like so
funny at the same I mean it's just so
ridiculous you know it was yeah I mean
we would just have these conversations
that nobody else could ever have with
each other now I think a lot of people
have those I bet those firemen have I
think a lot of people do that a lot of
people do that I just don't think he
necessarily can do it now because
there's cameras and microphones and yeah
God knows what everywhere you go yeah
you know you can't do a good rape joke
anymore right what kind of world do we
live in it all right let's listen to
another one of these guys here one of
these people here's some more uh life
advice because initially your confidence
is an ego trip it's not rooted in
anything real right and then you get
your ass kicked yes
and nearly have the light stomped out of
you uh-huh
and they're forced to anchor down into
the truth of who you are into your
integrity and then you start to build a
new Foundation of confidence that's
built on
[__] rock bed an unshakable Rock bed
oh look at this guy play with his toes I
like the guy he's sitting Indian style
like that guy's never gotten the shook
if you could if I got the [__] kicked
out of him he'd know God damn well you
don't play with your toes sitting like
that next to this [__] Lumberjack
it's flat smear of a man giantism voice
he has
[Laughter]
I mean I've seen like I mean that is
just disguise he's sitting there look at
this guy he got this [__] kicked out of
him I mean he's a mountain of a man with
a sleeve tattoo I get this [__] kicked
out of me I became a comedian like I
knew I wasn't going to become John Wick
but the listening would you call it
active listening is so infuriating just
yes yes yes yes it's this way people
listen to each other when they're it's
just like it's just a rote phrase they
use again and again you'll you ever see
that like on talk shows somebody'll just
be like thank you thank you yes it's so
awesome it's like you didn't listen to a
word this [__] just said but it's just
their there was a waitress at the cellar
I think we talked about that the level
of anger anger that just came up with me
was somebody going thank you thank you
it's like will you that's not even a
real [__] emotion or a response it's
so stupid I remember I this my wife was
into this this thing on on uh NPR right
it's always funny she puts on NPR and I
just [__] trash everybody everybody I
mean even though I'm [__] liberal but
just they're so nauseatingly liberal
yeah it's just [__] horrible right
um
I remember some comedian was on there
was talking about the [__] UCB back
when the old scene was like to be like
the our [__] jokes or sit on a [__]
royal pillow right and they were going
like ah the guy goes oh the [__] he
goes oh they're UCB that that crowd
those are the comedy connoisseurs ugh oh
my God I was just like no it isn't they
[__] watch Iron Man like you do Iron
Man or whatever you so they'll watch
your 20-minute Captain America [__]
bit connoisseurs is in fear yeah awful
so anyway so we're listening to NPR
and This Woman's on there black woman on
this these uh these two white women you
know who who I I think you know they
think they're [__] you know you know
the shoulder thing that you do so they
just want to have they're so they're so
elated that a person of color is on
their [__] thing and she was
discussing whatever her [__] theory
was about how we now live in this
corporate world and you don't even put
any value on your private time actually
what she say was making a lot of sense
and I'm listening to her and as she was
in the middle of one point the sidekick
just goes yes
like that [__] long
disruptive too it's like oh you think
that was disruptive my wife couldn't
hear the rest of the interview because I
just kept going yeah
yeah you know what I don't like about it
too is it's a way to steal focus and act
like oh yeah I thought that I already
thought of that yeah I thought that
thank you that was mine no finally she
said the thing that I've been thinking
and I'm now going to take credit for it
yes they're saying you got the question
right when it wasn't even their thought
they're like correct they're selling
they're telling the person they're
correct yes I already perceived of this
Noble Pious lofty spiritual idea Rachel
Rachel thank you thank you what you just
said that was powerful thank you thank
you thank you for saying that we needed
this thank you [__] you yeah I wish do
we have any of those clips oh I love the
strong women ones that these guys strong
women I see you you ever met a woman who
hustles hard
[Music]
has a slick mouth and will cuss you out
that's her
gently walking with the long trench coat
what kind of J crew commercial and he
just took the footage is that what it
was in a dramatic [__] music and then
everybody look at that that's me
that's me that's how I am I'm wearing a
comfy turtleneck with just a gentle cup
of cocoa in my dumb hands how what does
this have to do with hustling she's
having an extremely relaxing day in
foliage and I like him how he like he he
Subs like subconsciously being like you
know putting that in it like he he
recognizes women like this and he can
handle a woman like he sees you I see
you I see what you're doing I see and
then of course she should be completely
fulfilled yeah that this guy actually
sees what the [__] she's doing which is
basically randomly walking around with
the turtleneck finishing a cappuccino
does she look like she has a slick mouth
like she would trash you
she looks like that would be like the
most boring [__] conversation just
sitting there with like I like I like
that time of year when pumpkin spice
comes out
it's like by the way I don't have a
problem with all that pumpkin [__] that
comes out sure why not it's a holiday
what does that to do with hustling it's
ludicrous I don't know she looks like
she's like relaxing on the cape or
something I mean it could be it could be
an ad for some sort of gentle vacation
that you needed from your real life yeah
it's outside waiting for a husband to
run back into the office to pick
something up and she just got herself a
cappuccino although that does that's a
pretty impressive cup I will say that
whatever whatever things she said but I
do think the guys that I think the guys
the guys narrating voice infuriates me
too because it's just such a he's just
like you said he's just casting this
wide net of like
I feel like that's the kind of guy
that's how he gets laid at a bar he's
like I see you you're the kind of woman
that does this and then everyone under
those videos they watch and they go
that's me I'm I'm a woman that works he
sees I'm seen
yeah no it is so that's why I think
there's actually a genius to what they
do yeah because I think there's so many
what really is the underlying thing of
this is the sadness in Walking
depression most people are in yeah that
they actually need something like this
yeah to make themselves feel good and
then you find out that that's actually
just [__] trying to pull it's like a
drag Star horoscope like oh I'm creative
and misunderstood
just to pull in numbers to make like
money I'd equate that too there was a
[__] thing at one point I was giving
20 of my advertising money to this uh
this this you know start not a startup
whatever a a charity and then I ended up
one week when the football game ended 60
Minutes came on you know and uh they
were doing this whole [__] Scandal on
the family that started this in the big
cars that they bought with it and all
that and it's just like it's just
[__] it's devastating so like I I
feel like that this [__] exists
somewhere in that world like let's just
tell
sad people who didn't get the love they
needed in life that they're special it's
sort of [__] what I like about is how
open-ended it is it's like what is that
even it's not attached and it's like
geometry right yeah well at least my
experience with geometry now me too I
was a hole in the team yeah it's like
that's not attached I see you it's not
anchored to any reality also I see you
like what's what's more passive than
that or what are you gonna do about it
you're gonna help this [__] out I like
that tired well when they always just
they're always discussing you know uh
either a man or woman that doesn't take
any [__] just showing footage of like a
predator some sort of lion or a cheetah
I know
there's always some Wilderness to
footage yeah praise standing out there
on the [__] planes
explosion Predators they're in the long
grass contemplating their next move in
such a hustler that's me I lay in the
long grass
[Laughter]
those are very guys watch more of that
the Lions and stuff like that do you
think it's so [__] more targeted to
men that want to be like I just think
that we all grew up too many of us watch
those testosterone movies and secretly
we all want to be the John Rambo of
whatever generation you are and you
gotta like stockpile all these weapons
and act like you know you are a threat
to somebody and somebody's gonna come
and like I just love like the uh like I
I actually you know I love guns I think
they're [__] cool [__] you know it's
provided you know some lunatic doesn't
get one but like those people that like
get to the point of like the gun
collection it's just like what the [__]
are you doing are you a pedophile like
why would you need this level of [__]
yeah what are you barbing for yeah it's
funny you say that because like
what if uh tyrannical [__] government
it's just like dude they will fly a
drone in here some nerd who sits Indian
style playing with his toes will fly a
[__] drone in here and [__] your [__]
up while you're watching the WWE you
won't even know what even happened you
won't even know it [__] happened you
know what you're prepping with your
[__] dumb stockpile this guy's gonna
press one small computer button now what
about the cops in San Francisco which is
right over there that's why I pointed
San Francisco uh [__] they they by a
narrow margin just got permission to
have a robot cop that can kill are you
serious and they're saying it's for uh
this is in San Francisco too which is
hilarious how do you go from funny place
to start all the leaves are brown it's a
[__] RoboCop man you must comply but
I they're saying it's for like when
somebody has themselves barricaded in
and they don't give a [__] and they
probably have all this like this
weaponry and [__] so but I don't know as
a paranoid person I'm like what are you
preparing to take away from us that
you're now [__] starting to have
these things and also like the the
comedy in that are they going to program
it to [__] like tow the blue line is
it going to be like a little [__]
racist
I
didn't say nothing
he had a gun on him
I think him reporting back reporting
he's talking to who who
oh my God who are the people that
[__] investigate the [__] cops oh
you're
you're sick he's just saying that I
don't know what you're talking about
he's a good man they program him it's
like evasive phrase
I do think she sells a lot of my things
on eBay you know when they take it like
Drug Money
I've never seen him go in the evidence
room oh my God
hold on one second sorry
they're gonna have to do something like
that oh my God eventually with uh uh AI
yeah huh I like that I just pulled that
out because it was a movie
artificial intelligence no but I mean I
do also feel like the guy the things
okay the cocktail the the first video
where they see the woman's hustle I see
you he starts making those videos for
other for depressed robots
your hustle
your hustle stride
a weak robot waits around for dw40 a
strong robot has his own can I see you
that the voice of that video that guy is
like he's the guy that yeah he he casts
this wide net with that he probably does
it's the kind of guy that says it says
the same horse [__] every time he goes
out on a date like he wears some some
scent he definitely has on a scent he
has some dumb [__] Shawnee DK Noir 50
years ago yeah
he's like this will get him I'll be
inserting myself inside her shortly he
just wants to be inside a woman so he
just has like seven phrases he uses and
then just eyes just evacuate his whole
head just evacuates I just I picture him
wearing all light brown yeah like a
light brown
sweater yep I remember one time breaking
up with this guy and seeing him out at a
bar that I still liked and he was
wearing one of those soft sweaters just
some baby blue kind of thing I'm wearing
but some horse [__] that I was like
don't put on that sweater like you're
listening to anyone like you're a
[__] raging drunk but I just I I saw
him in that bar and I just was thinking
about like the whatever dumb lies he was
gonna whisper to some person that is
such a great move put on a safe gentle
top like you're gonna [__] I respect
for anyone yeah if you're raging
alcoholic and you're not going to listen
to a woman in your life you have to wear
a soft you have to get like a pastel
sweater you got to get your foot in the
door I'm like what do you do who you
would [__] run on a beach with your
keys you know like because I would tell
them not to drive who are you to put on
a [__] yellow soft sweater and act
like you're going to be present for
anyone how long did you date a raging
alcoholic for a couple of them back oh
that's amazing
I mean this guy was he was wild like he
I mean it was insane that I like the
crazy guys I when I was first living in
New York we just ate back to back these
just code red I mean throbbing
alcoholics
this guy was an emergency just bottle
strewn across oh my God like he was uh
and the thing is I would put men on this
pedestal funny that I was like your
apartment to me seemed amazing like I
was impressed that I was friends with
someone with an apartment that's how
that's how lost I was a door I was like
Billy's got an apartment and he wants to
be my friend
like I put people on such pedestals
because I was just homeless like I was
in my own gray garden situation with
with Sherrod and Tony so in any whenever
a man just would have like a a job in an
apartment I mean this guy was he was a
foreman he looked kind of like Paul
Newman very much like my type just a
Dusty working class alcoholic you know
it's just the kind of guy looks like
good looking guy [__] gorgeous yeah
he looked like I mean he was gorgeous
alcoholic yeah [__] hot he had bright
red eyes we found right red just his
eyes were always red when he would drink
they would just get right oh okay but he
was like he was a little Dusty just dumb
as a [__] rock
how I liked him just absolutely nothing
inside their heads we would have been a
great man you just love some dumb boozy
[__] just sticking her jugs in your
face that's what I like I love to give
like an old Saloon [__]
I mean he was vacant just vacant but he
we found him actually we found him on
the street we were on we stand at me and
Marina we were at stand up New York and
she was like there's this guy outside
who's violently drunk he's your type
because she knew that I like kind of a
Dusty looking guy that looked like he
could fix things like your alcoholic
madam
it's a good question I got a woman for
you buddy
some debris on the street that's gonna
type okay before you hit that cop I got
I got a woman I got a woman I want you
to meet and he was
he knew she knew that my type was yeah
that kind of because it's everything
opposite of what I came from like you
know my dad couldn't fix anything his
name's Howie Feinstein like he had a
never-ending sinus infection like he
didn't know how to operate like a fuse
box or food Howie Howie he didn't go by
Howard no Howie and he had such a sinus
infection he was just the opposite of a
man in every in all of those ways you
know like my friends used to be like oh
I get it yeah I get it yeah he was like
my friends would be like oh your dad
told me about a sinus infection I'm like
can you not tell my friends like he
would tell people to call the house but
anyways so I can't get rid of it oh my
God it's so embarrassing I'm like dating
this guy and he's like yeah your dad's
satisfaction sounds really wrong
but anyway so we went out I Swang way
the other day you watched HUD yeah all
these Paul Newman movies
I love those old movies where the guys
were just these [__] Dusty rocks and
so like so who who was the guy who are
the guys you liked growing up so the
Stars the Stars I'm trying to think of
who I liked growing up I mean Charles
Bronson I don't think I knew of those
when I was when I was really young I
remember my mom like walked in on me I
was probably like 10 French kissing a
Michael J fox poster he was
actively Frenching the poster and I told
her that I was cleaning it
oh God I didn't have a save ready so I
was like I'm cleaning it did she put her
leg up and then want to discuss the
whole embarrassment she goes I she goes
I lived in California in the 1960s
that's what she always said when she
knew she thought I was like lying to her
she's like oh please Rachel I lived in
California in the 60s I've heard all the
lies there's no way you're licking a
poster clean like she needed that
reference anyone would I just had
nothing else to say you walked in the
night with my [__] mounding out with
this post I just used to lay it on my
dump bed you might fool some of these
other East Coast people but I lived in
California in the 60s she would say that
everywhere she would say if you're at a
restaurant the waiter would be taking
too long to go please take your time I
lived in California in the 1960s
I remember my dad wanted to get out of
the medical field because he always felt
like there was an easier job and people
were making more money and he was just
sitting there talking about how he
wanted to open a diner my mother and I
would have to listen to it like this is
normal and it was Christ you know you
order your cheese you know it's like ten
dollars Christ these guys selling slices
of pizza I mean they're making two three
four five thousand dollars a day
you know what I mean sit there with like
listen to this madness I'll tell you I'm
a hell of a short order cook dude and he
cooked everything on high Really Cooking
everything on high yeah his big thing
was he made poached eggs every year they
would be [__] watery he was too
impatient to toast the bread so it'd be
like white bread and then he would take
the wet egg he didn't even use a slotted
spoon and would just set it on there so
you'd have you'd have an undercooked wet
egg on one like
hey Bill how many you want I'll take one
oh yeah you don't want two I think one's
good
can you imagine how different our child
does would be if our parents would have
just crunched on one medication my dad I
love my parents when I was just the [__]
they did but it's funny no it's hilar I
had really good parents too but they
were like good people they were there
for me but I mean like anxiety like you
know they needed therapies I don't think
I became a comedian because of of uh
your parents no I don't and I don't
think I don't think anybody and I don't
think any of this [__] it's an innate
ability yeah there's [__] that happened
to me I don't think is really led to
that necessarily I just think see what
you're saying yeah no I just always
liked [__] around and making people
laugh yeah and fortunately
there was a job that you could do
because before that you would just call
the jerk off
yeah yeah I'm not making that guy I'm
Foreman that guy's a jerk off he's
always screwing around you know you just
you just stayed driving the forklift the
whole time you never got to that place
where you started telling people what to
do unless you took some responsibility
and you stopped joking around right I
think that's how things used to work
back in the day then
like I I agree with you no and and my
family my five like really good parents
that were there for me and stuff but
it's funny too specific cocktail of
dysfunction you agree with me because
you see me because I see you and I see
your power I see you thank you thank you
thank you I mean shut the [__] up
really well waitress did this at the
seller it was like the most random
person it was like Horatio Sans this is
like so many years ago she saw him at
the cellar and she just prayed to him
she went
thank you I'm like who did you just
think it's just some random X Cosmos
member of SNL she just went thank you
you must have had that have you had
anybody yet just grab your hand clasps
your hand and thank you for some [__]
joke you told me yeah some [__]
[__] yeah just thank you
thank you no it's just like hey man I
like your [__] you're funny that's good
oh it starts getting closer listen
I was in the middle of losing a house
and it's just like please oh I know
please don't put this on me it gets a
little dicey doesn't it and I'll tell
you the weirdest [__] it's like I think
I I was the first thing you put on I did
not help you through losing a house they
just want to tell somebody that story
they want to tell somebody and you're
the person that they're going to tell
well I get weirded out and walk away you
on the other hand go in for the slow hug
yes I can see you just being like
[__] every boundary up which is
better better But yeah I I definitely
like
um Zoom towards those guttural
alcoholics
the guy we found outside stand up of
course foreign no it's okay I it's I
think he might be amused by how insane
this is because it's everything you
would run fast away from okay it comes
into Santa New York starts drinking with
us says he just got back from the war
already I love this I'm like this is
what I want like so did Marina bring him
in yeah I mean she wasn't like she
wasn't really wrangling him she grabbed
his raincoat and just I think she talked
to him outside or something and she's
like I buy this guy in the show he's
kind of cute or something like and then
so I mean it was I don't know it wasn't
good but she wasn't like
alcoholics need love too yeah why not so
we all went out and drank with him some
more exactly what he needed and then um
he told me that he just got back from
the war
okay and I didn't remember what worry
was he was just but again it was just my
type just PTSD freshly traumatized like
this works for me you know so we go out
a couple times he has a [__] limp
okay he's limping Billy he has some sort
of War limp I'm like hot all of it yes
he's all I just thought he was a regular
drunk now I feel bad if he was not
performing now I feel bad wait wait no
you won't my friend okay then on like
the third date he tells me I wasn't in
the war oh no no he says listen I got
something to tell you
I wasn't actually in the war like I just
thought I'd never see you again I'm like
with the limp he's like yeah you know
and he's like I've had some other issues
but I wasn't in the war I'm just I fell
off almost a carpenter it fell off
moped and you stayed I not only stayed I
moved in with him
what I moved myself in
well you know a relationship is built on
lies and not alcoholism all right so I
was like oh maybe I can I can I can
clean this guy up
so I moved in with them I mocked him
heavily for the war thing I used to get
him I used to get him books with old War
photos and kiss them like with lipstick
and write funny little things like love
Lorraine like you know like a little
battle notes of them I would just mock
him and trash him about it and I figured
like I could I could sober this guy up I
mean I was like 24. you know I was a
deep idiot so I move in with him he
starts playing this game this [__]
interactive war game one of those things
called like Aces High so he had like
Rudder pedals and like he would you know
it sounds like a cool game yeah he had
the hell so I tried to bribe him to stop
drinking by saying I would get him like
fancy or like ruddle Rudder puddles
pedals sorry that he could like operate
his game with or something it worked for
like two weeks he would get on this game
and would refer to it as if it was a
real war he's like yeah you didn't
[__] support me in my battle tonight
you asked nothing about it we invaded a
small village it's pretty tricky
you weren't there for me wait did he
have like a soldier fantasy yes
I remember one time we were fighting and
he was like let me just joined exactly
he said his biggest life was was not
being in the military and I was like you
deserve to be with someone that doesn't
think that's hilarious
what did he say I don't know what he'd
say he's [__] wasted out of his mind
how long did you stay with this guy like
three years
three years he to go on the road with me
and we would go to air shows did I even
meet this guy I don't think you ever met
him I think I I couldn't bring him
around too much because at a certain
point in the night he would start
glaring at someone he was one of those
guys that was good for a few hours and
then he would just like pick a rival at
the bar and the rivals would get funnier
and funnier like we would drink at this
port authority bar and it was like he
just started glaring this one and this
guy was like Jack like he was a strong
big dude he started trying to have a
Face-Off with like some elderly Widow at
the bar he's like you didn't see the way
she looked at me I'm like Virginia like
she's 70 years old what beef could you
possibly have with this woman I got it I
know a guy uh
he's going through some [__] like that
he's he's like
he's like 10 years older than me yeah
and he told me a story the other night
of being in a bar by himself passed out
uh he was in there with his dog and he
passed out and he woke up and there was
these three guys laughing at him oh no
he said what
oh my God
he said he said to the guy hey buddy why
don't you shut the [__] up before I [__]
you in the mouth
oh my God
and I was like you said that by yourself
I go did you get the [__] kicked out of
you I guess not I could have [__] them
all up and I was he a big dude and then
he goes and then he tells me in the end
then he goes
I love him to death
he goes
yes and this woman threw me so I had to
get my dog and I left and I didn't even
know his dog was there I should have
said that the beginning of the story and
he just he was passed out and his
[__] dog is sitting there like like
you like you dating an alcoholic yeah
this is the guy I'm with yeah I would
have to at the end of the night I'd have
to convince them not to fight Virginia
or whatever he would accuse me always of
not having his back the typical rage
never has my [__] back and I'm like
with Virginia come on you know like some
imagined perceived enemy of his and then
I remember one night he was like what
did not have in your back because you
just didn't agree that that didn't agree
engineering was uh yes these people
didn't even know where you weren't even
aware what started it did she like music
better than First Blood the fact that I
was even
foreign
there usually wasn't very much
conversation at all I mean the fact that
I wasn't particularly tell you something
sweetheart you can take that Glenn
Miller and shove it up your ass Glenn
Miller can't touch Metallica
that's the kind of fights he would get
in just like this band versus that band
ah I remember being tired in so many
bars just him screaming at some guy
about whether one movie was better than
another whichever one you liked is
better shut the [__] up let's go home
all right let's let's uh you know what
why don't we watch another clip we'll
watch another clip here
clippity click clack clip
all right we'll watch one more clip
oh god listen to this music
[Music]
oh this is just this idiot that built
this big house I talked about this let's
let's go to another one I just want more
self-help
[Music]
yeah when I take I I got a pilot's
license I don't know if I told you that
so cool yes I fly a helicopter and I fly
people over that house really
Savage Beauty all right just just go
back to the beginning powerful body
just go back to the beginning all right
when I'm not talking if you could just
do it
[Music]
Savage Beauty
look at that powerful body
strength Grace magnificent form I can't
tell the difference how does a tiger
manage to keep himself at the peak of
physical fitness for his entire life
he doesn't lift weights work machines
perform calisthenics or aerobics and he
doesn't jog to head off a man
his power comes from his own exercise
system
far different from man's and also far
superior it is the ultimate exercise
system which I shut this off tiger moves
ironically when man sets about to
improve yeah you never see a tiger doing
flies I think you guys making a great
point that they can tear the head off a
man well it [__] weighs 800 pounds
I was trying to say as I always over
talk everything he also isn't doing a
plank the entire time the tiger yeah it
is in like a plank position
um this guy's [__] jacked like what
are they talking about when is that from
that's classic 80s I mean that shirt all
of it the glasses are amazing now I mean
that those glasses now just make you
look like a serial killer
I mean if anyone has those on now
they're making a suit out of your skin
wasn't it weird how that whole [__]
Jeffrey Dahmer thing became like this
like mini series that everybody was just
watching it was a little uncomfortable I
don't understand any of that [__] where
it's just like no this really happened
and there's people that had you know
like I I understood people getting upset
with that yeah it was insane and also
like there's dude the early years no
nobody needs to stroll down memory lane
he says psychopath that devastated
people it's so strange and they'll try
to also there was one what was that
movie where like Zac Efron which serial
killer did he play they were trying to
make it like he was hot or something it
was Bundy it was Bundy yeah and they
were trying to like well Zac Efron's a
good looking guy he is I mean was was
what's his face a good looking guy who
that [__] guy that hate the people oh
the uh oh um Jeffrey Dahmer wait did he
play Ted bunny or Jeffrey Dahmer he
played Ted Bundy now that I think about
it I mean Ted Bundy was like good
looking for a murderer they tried to
make him into a hunk I'm not really sure
that why that was necessary but they
tried to kind of like make it some sort
of heartthrob it was so well because
there was there's always like whenever
somebody's on trial for something
horrific I mean you think you're bad you
know pulling these lushes out of the
[__] gutter it's like people you know
like guys on death row get like marriage
proposals they get massive amounts of
ass it's true like well potentialism or
potential yeah they can't actually
unless they have access to them because
they would kill them yeah but no a lot
of them do they get like they get
letters and letters and marriage
proposals well it's the ultimate
Fixer-Upper yeah you're right yeah
I remember having this long conversation
on the road once with this club owner
and she was talking about this guy she
was dating and I was like just analyzing
their relationship and stuff at one
point I was like oh when are you gonna
see him she's like well he's
incarcerated now I was like wait what
and she met him like Wally is in prison
wow like wait a second
ever just think you're having like a
genuine conversation about something I'm
like I was trying not to laugh I was
like wait
and she's just like my boyfriend
what and what was he in jail for I can't
remember I think I just checked out at
that point I like got disassociated
fully but he had been jail for a few
years I mean he was wrongly in prison
for beating his last wife to death
oh Jesus
I had a blast hanging out with you I
don't think I've hung out with you for
like an hour in forever I know
everything's good fun yes family kid
everything yeah I've got a kid it's
weird it's exciting it's cool well you
were funny when we came in you were in
total mom mode I brought cleaning up
some coffee yeah I I uh it's it's fun I
didn't nobody prepared me for how funny
it is right like kids and stuff like
there's a lot of hilarious things that
happen all the time so it's kind of like
it's fun but it's also sort of hilarious
I just like when they learn something
yeah like my son he's two and a half and
now he what's that like you'll say
something all right finish finish up
your vegetables he goes what's that he
says what's that that's hilarious like
where did you learn that
and he loves syrup you're being syrup
syrup syrup and it's like I already put
it on there but he has to see you he
doesn't trust like come on man let's
stay come on don't give me the oil you
put it on so I'll put it on he instructs
it and then and then he was putting it
on he goes he goes oh yeah
oh yeah
he's picked him up out of the chair and
I don't know where he just goes crazy
crazy he's just picking up everything
but what's funny is how old is he now
two and a half it all kind of honest the
best my daughter too he likes
motorcycles fire engines trucks yeah
garbage trucks like have you seen have
you watched the um those YouTube videos
they'll just have a they'll have like an
hour of just fire engines driving by oh
my God yeah she my daughter likes fire
engines too probably because of Pete but
she loves any fire engine footage and
she also
um she does some of that same stuff
where she calls me sweetie a lot like
the other day I was leaving for the
seller and I was like I'll see you in
the morning she goes go ahead sweetie
sweetie just go ahead sweetie my
sister-in-law was like she called me
sweetie too can you imagine this two and
a half okay guess that from you from
your husband she probably gets it from
me I probably call her sweetie but she's
like she goes go ahead sweetie go ahead
like don't dismiss I just wiped your ass
like she acts like she's like an elderly
waitress at a diner she's like oh sure
sweetie sure sweetie she also listens to
me like this she goes
I mean you can't listen like that you're
too like you haven't been through you
know I have a burden that you're
referring back to like she listens like
this like she'll be like
she puts her hand up now when he goes to
like leave to go to another room he
kisses you on the cheek and he goes I
miss you too oh my God it's so hilarious
but also so adorable that's so no he's
like he's like the sweetest kid ever and
then like when something doesn't work
like a toy like he'll pick up one of his
trucks he's just like ah [__] throws
it
across the room
and it's freaking my wife out because
I'm just like it's just testosterone
it's normal it's just it's what they do
he's frustrated this is good he's
understanding that things aren't working
but he has thrown a few things that's
what my nephew fat people and [__] so we
we kind of got to watch out for that but
um I unfortunately I gotta I gotta get
back to uh something else uh hilarities
New Year's Eve I mean you're not gonna
find somebody kill you my New Year's Eve
what'd I say you said hilarity I'm sorry
helium sorry one of those H clubs
hilarities in Philadelphia New Year's
Eve you're not going to find anybody
funny you make me laugh more than
anybody I know you're [__] hilarious
thank you so much thank you for watching
the podcast and this comes out next week
right up happy uh Merry pre-Christmas
Hanukkah Kwanzaa whatever the [__]
you're into I carry your [__] family
please say that take care of yourself
Christmas I'll see you thank you Billy
[Music]
hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's the Monday Morning podcast for
Monday November no sorry December
December sorry
about that December 15 2014
sure some nervous like oh you [__]
uploaded the robot again
epic fail
what a [__] loser man
oh you internet [__]
just up the [__] ass all the goddamn
time you know it's some [__] very rarely
very rarely do I do I ever block anybody
on Twitter
just because I don't want to give people
the satisfaction that they bugged me and
this technology [__] [__] bugged me
he oh you know what I'm what am I an
[__] how long have I been in this
internet game I'm going to tell you what
the [__] he said I'm not going to tell
you what he said go [__] yourselves look
at you guys all warming up your [__]
little flangies there to go send me a
[__] tweet
I know what the flanges tassels made of
Tassels flanges
that's on your feet right and then
carpal's metacarpals phalanges remember
that
when you took biology class and they
talked about the bile juices whatever
the [__] they did
well the whole thing is connected to
your respiratory system now the
respiratory system is has fascinated
scientists
for centuries
um oh God did that bring back some
[__] bad goddamn
Memories the only good about I think one
of my science classes is that like you
know with the books back in the day you
had to sign your name
in the year you had the books so then
you get books you know you know somebody
in a great above oh you got your old
math book right the only good about my
science class was I got the same book as
the hottest chick two grades in front of
me
you know
so I was just sitting back there with my
orange hair not even listening just
being like she actually held this book
oh my gosh
[Laughter]
that was the only thing enjoyable
about science class what's funny now is
I I love science
I love [__] science the sound of the
[__] the [__] crap the ozone layer
what was that I love a parade
how simple was life back then when you
could just write a song
you could write a song like that first
of all no one would even question your
sexuality right you could just [__]
rattle one of those off the sound of the
bait the [__] Trumpets like I'm
walking by
of course you love who didn't love a
[__] parade what else were you doing
standing around
going out and shooting a [__] varmint
dragging it in carrying it by its
[__] tail
[__] wife with a huge dress goes all
the way down to her ankles and up to her
[__] chin
you know nothing to look at where were
all the [__] back then
it's not like there was a brothel
what did you [__] would you rub one
out to
imagine if I had a new horse right is
that what you
[Applause]
there was no celebrities
what the [__] did you do back oh yeah
you just [__] were trying to live
you know
you had to worry about the [__]
Native Americans coming back to take
what was rightfully theirs
okay and I can guarantee when they came
over the hill the last thing they were
doing was going
[Applause]
back those [__] things
those [__] things those you know I
was already trying to think of the
animal to compare it to sorry didn't
mean didn't mean to offend any casino
owners out there
those [__] people
yeah you had no idea remember that that
[__] line and Good Fellas
the second I heard all the noise I knew
they were cops if they were Wise Guys I
wouldn't shut the [__] up
they were Native Americans you'd be
[__] hanging upside down by a tree
right above your Cadillac before you put
the keys in the ignition you'd have no
[__] idea and then they'd slowly skin
your life or break you on the Wheel
all right
Henry Hill
um
I don't know what the [__] I'm talking
about uh whatever this [__]
technology [__]
you know it's like all you douchebags
last last week when I was calling iCloud
SoundCloud and you guys thought it was
[__] hilarious I actually was proud
of the fact that I don't know what the
[__] it's called
you know is that your big [__] claim
to fame all you [__] douchebag at
least not not all of you just that small
they just you guys you live
you get on the you start you let me tell
you something all right you middle of
nowhere [__]
staring at a computer screen [__] you go
start a podcast you rip for a [__]
hour and 20 minutes all right you're
gonna make some mistakes half the time
you're trying to think what the [__] am
I gonna talk about next to what I'm
saying I was talking to DeRosa we did an
uninformed
I was all excited about those
Mercedes-Benz that I checked out and all
that [__] and I I [__] up I was
talking about a wagon I was out of this
four-door uh uh Coupe or whatever and so
he's like
serious
[__] guy
all capital letters freaking the [__]
out because I said four-door Coupe
instead of sedan
it's a two door
[__] fail
you know what it is
what I shouldn't do is I shouldn't get
upset by that nitpick and stuff what I
should really do is read between the
lines and see the misery of that
person's life that they they just live
for that [__] moment
sitting around listening to a Goddamn
podcast waiting for somebody some
uneducated [__] to [__] up so you can
write in
right and feel better about the
all-weather carpet underneath your
[__] hammer toes
I know it's the holiday season
up your damn ass girls we're going to
the Christmas tree store
he's got a red [__] suit with some
cotton glue to it
he's probably 23.
is that the worst when they get the
[__] an awful Santa Claus
it's like can you even try
I mean it's a [__] woman
okay she's got blush on
you know we make a great Santa Claus Tom
Coughlin or the New York Giants that guy
would make a great Santa Claus because
Santa Claus is not obese
he was considered a fat [__] when I was
a kid that's how that's how [__] up my
country is right now that's how out of
shape we are that like uh what's his
face like uh Santa Claus isn't really
considered fat anymore
what would you call them husky if he had
to go buy a new red suit
all right when would he get that
he probably does it sometime in the
[__] summer like I gotta do this
[__] [__] again you know he takes off
like January to May and then in June
that's stretching out the old hammies I
gotta get another [__] suit Jesus
Christ
I'm not gonna have to shut up lady all
right I'm sick of the [__] else they
make the same goddamn thing every day
every [__] year save goddamn soup all
right so what does he do he shaves the
beard he gets a [__] haircut he rolls
down to [__] Tom Ford
gets himself a fitted red suit you know
but they don't think he sees a fatty
you know that's how [__] up at this
point like that guy would be considered
like uh not even a Cruiserweight
if he boxed he'd be like welterweight
and despite the fact that he has a
sleigh that can fly around the [__]
world your average fat [__]
sitting in a Taco Bell could beat him in
a [__] fist fight
no matter how Nimble he is
how much how much Christmas dust he
sprinkled on his [__]
Jerry Garcia haircut there'd just be
some tub of [__] just leaning on him
leaning on just wearing them down round
after round
he's keeping that one [__] keeping
that arm up you know left keeping that
left up just covering this [__] big
Ted Kennedy fat [__] head leaning on
Santa Santa's working the [__] body
all right old Tubby's just eating him up
he's [__] leaning on him
Santa loses his hat halfway through the
first round
gets in the corner right takes off his
jacket he's got some stained wife beater
on the fat [__] you know doing the Ali
thing he doesn't I don't need a chair
you know right he's just [__]
standing in the corner right they
already got that [__] cold compress
right on [__] Santa's face
I think what I'm talking about all right
all I know is it's Christmas and we're
like [__] 10 days away and I haven't
even [__] started
oh you know Dasher and Dancer and
Prancer and victim no I don't what I was
standing there you didn't even introduce
me comment and Cupid and Donner and
Blitzen
but do you recall
would you shoot a reindeer would you
shoot a reindeer
would you do it what if your plane
crashed up near the North Pole you know
there it was you couldn't shoot [__]
Rudolph that's like shooting Elvis you
can't do that [__] you gotta wait for
him to OD
D OD sitting on a [__] reindeer
toilet which is basically what anywhere
it's standing
you know I'm so [__] against
technology people I just I've had it I
just [__] I like I know all the [__]
that it does for you and how convenient
it makes it and all of that [__]
oh by the way you know what pissed me
off I was watching this the [__]
commercial where they talk about like
the first uh
you know how the first half time came
about was basically people you know
these [__] you know racist white guys
I mean
you know they were back then right Jesus
Christ the [__]
anybody in a striped [__] uniform
with no face mask I mean you could only
imagine what was coming out of red
Granger's miles back in the day the
Galloping ghost right
so they got this commercial where it's
like supposed to be that error and these
guys are playing football and they're
talking about how the first halftime
came around and basically how it came
around was these guys were playing and a
bunch of [__] ladies
came by with some pop that came by with
like some Coke or whatever Pepsi or
[__] I don't know what tab I don't
know what they brought
the whole [__] thing is
you know
it's just a metaphor right it's like
you're a guy you're on point you have a
[__] goal and what happens [__]
walks in the room and everything gets
thrown to the Wayside the next thing you
know you're 53 going wait a minute what
the [__] happened
huh I wanted to be an astronaut
I I wanted to learn how to play the tuba
I want it all in a [__] hair salon
what happened
[__] came into the room you took your
eye off the ball and you started
drinking some pop
I hate how they say that in the midwest
the fact that they call it pop and then
they say pop you want some pop
no do you got any soda
soda what's that
I can't do a Midwest accent as you can
see I gotta be out there hanging around
with those [__] um
hang on just remind me of something
about the southern tour I want to do
next [__] I gotta type that in so I
write that I say it later anyways
it's a long story short
because the women show up these guys who
are [__] knocking the hell out of
each other basically inventing the NFL
they stop
and they look at each other and like hey
you know uh maybe uh one of them will
give us uh one of them [__] 23
skadoos over there what do you say what
if he just knock off for like 15 minutes
go over there or Sprite
you know the guy's like what the [__]
a Sprite it doesn't exist yet douchebag
so all right let's get a Coke it has got
to be Coca-Cola right
was that the first one they went over
there right the original Coca-Cola had a
little bit of blow in it
next thing you know they're dumping it
down her ass crack
right the whole [__] game goes out
the window but that's not the problem
that I have with that commercial the
problem I have is in the middle of it
somebody takes an old-timey camera turns
it around on him and does a selfie now I
know the people
who made that commercial I'm going to
give them the credit to be like they
realize that nobody took a [__]
selfie back then okay nobody took a
[__] selfie not only did you not take
a selfie nobody smiled in photos back
then
I don't know when the [__] that started
but if you look back in the day nobody
is smiling in photos unless you caught
him off guard
okay
they were doing a little jig or some
[__] and you took a picture with that
[__] cannon that [__] gunpowder
[__] when I'm sorry for everybody's
ears there I didn't realize I was gonna
be that loved [__] would go off in
the background right
and then you know that then the guy be
like you just take my [__] picture
yeah well then what's all the smoke in
the air for huh
you keep that [__] witchcraft away
from me buddy
right nobody [__] smile
you understand when they took pictures
of the Native Americans the reason why
they didn't smile
their whole [__] world was going to a
hell and a [__] handbasket by a bunch
of [__] douchebags
whose ancestors were eventually going to
walk around wearing those [__] Beats
by Dre
which aren't even that good at
headphones
oh now they're Wireless
tell you what [__] the technology making
them [__] know invisible wires why
don't you make them good
somebody gave me I got a [__] pair of
those goddamn things I was listening to
a [__] [__] year and I finally just
sat around yeah these things aren't that
good
I can hear the music
but it's not blowing my mind
you know what beats by Dreyer and this
isn't against Dr Dre because he already
sold the company he's sitting on a
billion dollars you think he gives a
[__]
he doesn't give a [__] plus I never
[__] trash anybody who's got a scar
on the neck okay that guy saw death
stared it down one and then one I'm
gonna come at him with wearing my
[__] PJs
I don't think so
all right and if you think I'm the kind
of guy who's gonna do something like
that you're listening to the wrong
podcast my friend
okay
anyways this is the Monday morning
podcast
you know it's ten days before Christmas
top click click click down through the
chimney with those Saint Nick what the
[__] did I remember that one
I was trying to sing one different you
know what [__] Christmas song I
absolutely there's a bunch of them that
I don't like
but the one that just really would wear
on me was Silver Bells
Silver Bells
silver or a Rocking around the Christmas
tree I'm white and I'm giving it a shot
I'm bobbing my head like a [__]
douche wearing this title suit
oh ho the mistletoe shoved up your
[__] plot
this is the this is when the guy Scott
sang it you know and he was just trying
to like feel out some words yeah well
we'll put Christmasy [__] in there let's
just jam with the band right one two
somebody suck my dick
oh right that's probably what they did
right down there Capitol Records
we have a Melody if you could just sort
of Riff on it yeah I can do that
jingle bells jingle bells jangling down
the street
I got a friend named Pete oh oh
something Christmas get her a gift maybe
that'll shut her the [__] up
listen I had my feeling today guys shut
it down shut it down
um all right it's probably oh you know
what it is time to do some advertising
the most important advertising that I do
all year so listen up everybody
all right listen up everybody the third
annual
Patrice O'Neal
um comedy benefit all right
is coming up on let me get everything
here the third annual Patrice O'Neill
comedy benefit you want to do something
great
okay that really
I'm not even [__] for the bottom of
my heart this has been such a great
benefit and has helped so many people
that Patrice loved in his life you know
that he was taken care of and all that
type of stuff this is just a wonderful
it's my favorite thing all year I get to
see all these great Comics that I never
get to see because we're always
traveling around it's the third annual
Patrice O'Neal Comedy benefit
uh Wednesday February 11 2015.
and it's going to be at 7 pm at the city
center where we always have it 131 West
55th Street between 6th and 7th Ave the
lineup will be Ben Bailey
Ben Bailey Boulevard uh one of my great
friends in this business been probably
done 9 000 shows with him cash cabs Ben
Bailey
this is all alphabetical order Colin
Quinn
David tell the great David tell
uh Hannibal Burris
Jim Florentine
Jimmy Norton Michael Che SNL's Michael
Che and Rich Voss and myself yours truly
you know Comics are so sensitive I gotta
[__] give a credit for all of them
all right SNL's Michael Che
Opie and Jimmy's Jim uh Jim Norton
uh uh cranky acres and uh that metal
show Jim Florentine creator of two
[__] shows that have made it onto the
air
surprising practically impossible
Hannibal Burris
the man who destroyed Bill Cosby
I'm [__] with you animal
um he didn't the person in the crowd did
sick of that [__] Comics tell a [__]
joke somebody records it and then they
got they talk to the [__] comic about
it
I didn't say that [__] to you I said it
to the people in the crowd I told a joke
in a comedy club not on a news program
you've brought the wrong person here on
split screen
um legendary Colin Quinn tough crowd SNL
one-man shows on Broadway
okay this man is leaving his dressing
room on Broadway
okay
he's leaving the Charles Nelson Reilly
Suite
to go do this taking time
out of his schedule
um it's going to be [__] awesome it's
great every year uh
uh if you want to get tickets you can
get them online at
newyorkcitycenter.org or over the phone
by calling City tickets
212-581-1212 once again it's
212-581-1212 if you live anywhere in New
York City you want to see one of the
best comedy shows of the year that also
all the proceeds
other than we got to pay to rent the
[__] building other than that they
all go to this is all this is above the
board there'll be no pink microphones no
mustaches grown
no support the troops and then I keep
all the [__] money none of that [__]
all right everybody's donating their
time this is it makes a great Christmas
gift and uh it's the best money you're
ever going to spend it's such a great
thing to do I absolutely love doing this
and I thank all the comedians
um over the years that have done this
and we're just going to keep expanding
it and I love this year that I love that
Michael Che and Hannibal Burris are on
it because now we've got some younger
guys that were actually influenced by
patrice's comedy if you don't know who
he is
um I'm actually jealous because now you
got to get to discover the funniest
[__] guy I ever met elephant in the
room download that please do all of this
legally uh so that the money goes to the
people he cares about
um
is great wonderful uh CD like whatever
you kids call it now downloadable
[__] CD LaserDisc thing uh Mr P uh
it's the funniest [__] guy I ever met
he's the best comedian I ever saw
and uh
if he was still alive I would have
chased him my whole career and I never
would have caught up and he would have
just continued to widen the Gap I mean
he just was the [__] man so please
for the love of God and we got a couple
hundred tickets left and uh
makes a great stocking stuff
um all right
now let's get to the [__] corporate
ones
um all right back to the podcast back to
the [__] podcast where the folks the
[__] podcasts you're scared wearing
[__]
um
all right what am I going to talk about
here uh where do we go where do we oh
you know what I had an acting gig uh
this past week and on Friday I got to
work with an actor named Brad Carter who
you guys have seen in a zillion things
and I was actually imitating him
uh back in the day when True Detective
came out and he played that inmate you
know
when uh Matthew McConaughey's character
goes in the guy went Reggie LeDoux
regular dude did that [__]
[__] unbelievable actor the next
thing you know old freckles gets it
acting gig and who am I sitting across
from this same [__] dude and he was
so goddamn funny and scary at the same
time all while eating bologna sandwiches
that's all I can tell you about it
uh but my face still hurts from trying
not to [__] blow takes uh
you know laughing because he's such an
and he always played like like character
actors are amazing to me like uh
they just how they make a living and how
much they have to hustle and all that he
was talking about how excited he was to
do something that was you know had a
comedy background and now he's always
playing these psychos and everything so
we're on like whatever the 10th take
he's on like his [__] ninth [__]
bologna sandwich
because he feels like he has to eat it
to get into this character which is
totally [__] working right
and I we end up asking them uh he
mentioned he had to be on set the very
next day at seven a.m and we're still
shooting it like [__] 10 at night
trying to get this [__] dog to walk
into the room sit down and look over at
the camera right and he says Ah because
I got to be on set tomorrow at seven I'm
like Jesus Christ I don't know how
you're doing he goes nah I'm low I love
it man I'm happy to be working so he's
talking about how he always plays
psychos I go uh what are you what are
you playing tomorrow because I'm playing
a rapist
[Laughter]
in a independent movie called eat me
um that's what there's that's that is
being made right now so look out for
Brad Carter he's shooting eat me right
now and uh watch True Detective and look
him up he also um had brain surgery
and uh for this little thing that he had
going on I let him explain it but this
is unbelievable video where he's playing
guitar he's a musician while they're
checking out his brain to see if they
put the thing in the right place it's
[__] unbelievable we'll we'll upload
it but uh you know if you really like
character actors and people just
disappear into it
to the point you're watching it going
where the [__] do I know this guy where
do I [__] all the Brad Carter that's
your man right there
um so anyways
let's let's get on to some [__] here
that I'm really excited about I know
that I've been bitching I know that I've
been moaning I know that I've been [__]
moaning and complaining
the whole time about this construction
downstairs guess what everybody it's
[__] done
the [__] is done there's a
couple little knickknacks they gotta
stick in these [__] I don't know the
plates over the light switches little
[__] like that
little [__] [__] like that and it
is [__]
awesome
absolutely beautiful absolutely gorgeous
it cost me a [__] fortune I will
never
make my money back in this house unless
I go vegan right now and try to live to
be 106 but I've just made the decision
that I'm not leaving
I'm not [__] leaving right
just all the [__] I'm erasing all the
[__] [__] who have lived here I'm
exercising the demons
of every one of these [__] that
went cheap
you know I got this ugly ass [__] I
don't even know what like there's no I
don't know what to tell you what the
colors of the rug in the bedroom that
I'm in right now so I'm thinking you
know this hardwood floor is underneath
this [__] thing
so I start to pull back the rug you know
for a future project and guess what's
under the rug
[__] plywood
and underneath the plywood is the
original hardwood floors
you know what kind of a [__] animal
you know what it was it was probably
done in the 70s
you know when wall-to-wall carpet was
just considered so [__] plush
what it was is after years of people
just walking around on wood first it was
dirt right
it's probably stone or some [__] right
he lived in a [__] cave
and then you just had Stone and the
[__] [__] was cold nobody could
afford rugs
right expensive or whatever your wife
started knitting one by the time she
finished it she had tuberculosis and she
died and every time he looked at the rug
he thought of her so you gave it to
somebody else
so people's feet they were sick of being
cold they get you know
again splinters and that type of [__]
which you know by back then you got an
infection and you [__] died or
somebody came in and sawed your foot off
right because he had a [__]
you know you bit down on a [__] Anvil
or whatever
because there was no anesthesia
so after centuries of that [__]
wall-to-wall carpeting seemed like a
good idea
you know
and uh
it wasn't
you know what's the most disgusting
thing
when it comes to carpeting is carpeting
in a bathroom every once in a while
right
I like you know you when they have like
an open house I'm one of those [__]
that just walks into your house and I'm
not gonna buy it because I just want to
look at it get ideas and just see yeah
how does this [__] douche living
right
it's like when you go to Elvis's house
you always feel like a creep you know
you go to Elvis's house and you want to
go in there and laugh at them then you
walk in there and you realize this was
his home
and I'm walking around it looking for
peanut butter and banana sandwiches
because I want to laugh at this guy and
it's just like this guy accomplished
more on a weekend than I ever did in my
life and he's buried in the backyard and
we just won't give the guy the peace
that he deserves they don't even spell
his [__] name right in the grave one
of the most exploited stars of all
[__] time you go across the street
there's a gift shop and they turn them
into a cuckoo clock and a [__] coffee
strainer and every [__] filter every
goddamn [__] thing you can think of
with Elvis on it you know
this is an Elvis fan
there's nothing Elvis about that press
the button
air right just start singing a song
they paint little mutton chops on the
[__] fan blades
so anyways every once in a while you'd
go into an old house
and you know what's my favorite thing
he's doing and you walk into an old
house and you smell an old person you're
like oh my God this [__] this was you're
gonna see [__] in here from the 1950s
right and you walk in there and you see
like the old kitchen and the old
bathrooms and all that and you just see
all the errors of styles
that the houses [__] lived through
you know
that [__] lime green
toilet seat cover or the plastic cracked
[__] toilet seat itself you know
where they made it like that squishy
[__] that was supposed to be comfortable
and it cracked after a while and then
they would just have wall-to-wall
Carpeting and you just sit there looking
at it going oh my God
the [__]
Health Department like like how many
restaurants
I mean if you had that in any restaurant
like like the 10 any restaurant within a
[__] five mile vicinity would be
[__] shut down
to have carpeting in a [__] bathroom
absolutely disgusting so anyways
um
so what I love about the downstairs now
is it's [__] it's level
it's clean everything works it's just
[__] awesome and it's right in time
for the [__] holidays
and um
I'm thrilled I'm thrilled with it you
know what's funny is the guy who sold me
this house he keeps calling me up every
once in a while right
you know they do they call you up like a
[__] old girlfriend
I can just feel you starting to love
your house so they gotta put that doubt
in your head hey Bill how you doing
I'll tell you it's a great time Michelle
but all over again
you know the great thing is when you
invest so much in your house that you're
never going to make any money off of it
you don't give a [__] anymore you're
like well I'm never leaving
I'm gonna redo this whole [__] thing
let me see if I can go broke on this
[__] thing
so um anyways you won't hear me bitching
about it anymore
um it's done and now that it's done it
looks [__] gorgeous and uh it was
worth every
every cent of it and your next question
is going to be bill can we see pictures
of it no you cannot no you can't what
are you an [__]
showing the pictures inside of my
[__] house isn't enough that I'm in
my house talking to you [__] creep
um anyways
hey look who've just walked in
oh needy face what uh why don't you grab
it grab a microphone
set up the old cord there
um
see what I wanted to talk about anything
here oh by the way as a New England
Patriot fan I am so [__] jealous of
the Seattle Seahawks defense man they
just look [__] great and I'll tell
you right I made fun of Pete Carroll for
years
and uh I was never more wrong I mean I I
never thought he was a bad coach or
anything like that but that [__] guy
is gonna go he already he's one of two
people who ever won
a a NCAA division one championship in
football and also won the Super Bowl the
other guy was Barry Switzer but you know
no disrespect to Barry he's a great
coach and all that type of [__] but he
he won with Jimmy Johnson's Team all
right Pete Carroll
you know
you know what happened the NCAA was the
wolf was at the back door he got the
[__] out of there and uh he went up
there what was Seattle at that point
they were nothing
and uh he's turned it around and he's
right now what you're watching Pete
Carroll do is one of the hardest [__]
things you can ever do is to have a team
that won the championship the year
before
come out and and somehow the next season
motivate them
where they're hungry not they want to
win it again they always want to win it
again but they they have a hunger in
them it seems when you're watching like
they haven't won it yet like they still
have something to prove and earlier this
season I really look at Pete Carroll and
Bill Belichick this year it was kind of
the same thing where the first six five
six games or whatever they had to figure
out what their team was because every
year people leave people come in it's a
little bit different and I'm watching
Pete Carroll do some Bill Belichick [__]
where it's like he knows what he has he
knows how to work it now he knows it's
thick the I don't know as much as my
Patriots are 11-3 I feel like I still
feel like the level of play in the NFC
uh is it's on it's another level
um I would never bet against uh
you know Belichick and Brady if anybody
could figure out how to [__]
I don't know Seattle looks like [__]
world beaters man so my money's on them
at this point
they just look like
they look [__] Unstoppable and uh
their QB their Wilson that guy is uh
is that even his [__] name so goddamn
old I can't remember names anymore that
[__] guy is the real deal you know
and all you [__] out there
who are starting to say verse he might
have been right about Mark Sanchez I
cannot help you I can't help first he
even texting me that dude I you know I
might have been right about this guy
it's like Paul you watched the first of
all Paul verzie is not right whether the
guy's great or whether he sticks Paul
verzie said after the first three games
of a quarterback's career this guy's
start like based on what Paul
based on what sitting at home watching
on a [__] TV never talking to him
never seen him in the locker room you
you threw a [__] Hail Mary
this is the deal with Sanchez okay I
think he's a good quarterback I think he
could win the Super Bowl with them but
the defense has to be unfucking
believable we're talking some I'm not
saying he's a Trent Dilfer he's beyond
that guy okay but to sit there and act
like this guy is
like on a Brady level a Peyton Manning
level like
Tom Brady Peyton Manning guys like that
and I even think there's Wilson guy like
is could get to that level like those
guys are so [__] good even if you
suck
even if everybody around them suck you
know as a wide receiver if you come in
there and you kind of stink and everyone
around you stinks and all of a sudden
you're the number one receiver because
everybody stinks you still know you're
getting a thousand yards because Tom
Brady or Peyton Manning's giving you the
[__] ball Sanchez is not at that
level all right that guy if he has a
great team he's great
and in other words he'll win the [__]
game but won't [__] it up all right but
when people start to leave and and the
talent level dips it's butt fumble time
okay and I did not see that ever with
somebody you know the higher guys
the Dan Marino's the [__] Peyton
Mannings the Tom Brady's okay so enough
with this [__] okay stop watching
[__] Football week to week and going
this guy is this and now he's this now
he's that go [__] yourselves all you
guys you guys can all go listen to the
[__] fursie effect
and [__] rub do a circle jerk and Pat
yourselves on the back with your
horrific predictions I love you Paul all
right
Nia
hi hey what's going on you're here just
in time for the um
for getting into the uh the questions I
uh perfect I told them boy let me turn
this up here uh I told them how the
downstairs is finally done
uh what do you mean I mean
yeah I know I'm not I cannot
muster
this endless enthusiasm that you seem to
have until it's done until it's 100
[__] done I know until every single
little piece is is done you know I
already went down there and there was a
couple of [__] things that I'm like
that's the thing that's why I don't keep
going down there see you keep going down
there every day and I understand that
it's important to check on it but like
you're like did you go downstairs like
every day and it's like I can't go
downstairs every day because I will see
a hundred things wrong with it and I'm
just I'm giving them time to do their
thing you know I'm like Hey we're done
then I can look and be like are you done
are you really done hey I'm Billy big
eyes Billy big eyes
bill foreign I still haven't seen your
billboard in real life
I want to see it you know what I'm
talking about
oh don't be so modest well that's a well
yeah what am I I'm gonna bring up a
[__] billboard on my own [__]
podcast well you didn't bring it up I
did hey by the way you know I'm very
proud of you you know thank you I'm very
proud to shut up
um by the way for all you guys like I I
somehow I just I sent a link do you
really want to get people going
send any sort of Link about global
warming
like the people who don't think it
exists like they always say the same
thing they go like
um explain the [__] polarized they
always talk about the Ice Age
the nice age of the ice caps well you
had the Ice Age and then it all melted
right right yeah the dinosaurs and then
what the [__] Ice Age came they died
whatever or a [__] meteor hit
whatever [__] happened right but
throughout history you sit there looking
at somebody who's [__] get a lazy eye
oh throughout history the [__]
players gone through periods of warming
up and cooling right you're talking to
like a dentist Jake and he and I'm
arguing and I'm a comedian it's just
like this is this is okay what they're
talking about is the rate the
unprecedented rate of how fast it is
heating up all right here's another
thing I just saw is that that's what the
argument is not whether or not the
planet heats up and cools down
throughout its [__] history it's the
unprecedented rate that it is doing a a
alarming rate
um I almost said get that word out my
hand what are you talking about even
nobody knows me I'm trying to fill a
[__] hour here there's over 5
trillion pieces of [__] plastic
estimated on and off estimated over 5
trillion people okay in the ocean okay
yes it's terrible I know yes I'm not
talking to you I'm talking to these oh
the few people give me [__] about that
sit there and act and think that we
don't have like an effect on this
[__] planet like do you know those
places in the United States where you
just can't live there
because of whatever we put in the ground
nuclear waste whatever [__] it's just
you can't [__] live there or you will
die nothing that is alive can live there
it's just dead zones name name one other
[__] animal I mean Gypsy Moss
caterpillar this is the closest thing I
can come from a what gypsy moth
caterpillars Gypsy moms caterpillars
it's a real thing yeah they just won't
won't coming up from the south
that doesn't help me Envision and they
they would just sit there and they would
eat up all the trees and stuff and
people would have to put like a little
piece of plastic around it I swear to
God you are talking about five different
things what are you saying you were
saying to you there are places that you
can't live and then you said there's a
mod except for the moth Gypsy like
they're the only ones that could survive
in these areas no I'm saying name
another animal that [__] affects the
planet the way we do adversely uh yeah I
don't I don't know I am not a um a
specialist in that area oh yeah you're
missing the whole point of this unlike
you you're missing I will not speculate
on it
you're missing the whole point of the
podcast this is what honey the point is
you don't know what you're talking about
but neither do you no I mean me oh I
don't know what I'm talking about I'm
saying when you come on the podcast you
don't know what you're talking about but
that by no means stops you from
pontificating that's true and throwing
out facts
that are facts in your world of science
in your world alone hang on I gotta read
two more advertisements here and then
we'll do the uh
we're gonna do the questions for the
week all right stamps.com everybody with
the holidays almost here you don't have
time to go to the Post officer to the
post office
with all the traffic in the parking and
the old ladies and then that douche who
shows up with 20 packages in front of
you you don't need it okay it's going to
be packed with everyone mailing out the
holiday gifts and packages there so do
what I do
usestamps.com instead with stamps.com
you can avoid all the hassles man of
going to the post office during the busy
holiday season everything you would do
at the post office you can do right at
home from your own desk all right or
your bed wherever the hell you put the
printer buy and print official U.S
postage using your own computer and
printer print postage for any letter or
package the instant you need it then the
mailman picks it up so easy and
convenient I use stamps.com to send out
all my posters I'm thinking of making a
poster by the way for that Australian
tour that's not how the [__] [__] I'm
gonna ship it over
other side of the goddamn planet
I don't know maybe I'll do that but if I
do I'm going to use stamps.com and you
know what when you send out your [__]
you should use stamps.com too right now
get this special offer when you want to
use my last name for b-u-r-r it's a no
risk trial plus 110 bonus offer that
includes a digital scale and up to 55
free postage don't wait go to stamps.com
before you do anything else you click on
the microphone at the top of the home
page and type in Burr b-u-r-r that's
stamps.com enter Burr and lastly but
certainly not leastly man great
everybody attention Grill Masters this
holiday season
there's only one gift
that is an absolute must-have the man
great what's a man great you might have
asked mangrates are American-made high
quality 100 percent cast iron grill
grates that sit right on top of your
existing grates weighing in at eight
pounds a piece mangrates and chairs are
juicy tender meat with no flare-ups and
a perfect sea amok every time mangrates
patented design delivers Steakhouse
quality flavor right at home take
advantage of the Monday morning podcast
special and get the man great for just
19.99 just head over to mangrate.com and
enter the our coupon code Burr b-u-r-r
at checkout also for a limited time
order four man greats and get the fourth
one for absolutely free time is running
out order today go to mangrate.com and
enter our coupon code Burr Burr at
checkout to take advantage of this
exclusive offer once again they're 100
American made 100 cast iron iron they're
19.99 special is limited time you can
order 4 man greats and get the fourth
one for absolutely free make sure to go
to mangrate.com and enter our coupon
code Burpee you are at checkout uh to
get this exclusive offer and that's all
other than if you're going to go to
amazon.com go to billboard.com first
click on the podcast page you click on
the link it takes you over there it
doesn't cost you any more money and they
kick a little money over my podcast if
you want to if you don't I totally
understand it all right let's get to the
content for this week
all right I already read about the
wonderful Patrice O'Neill benefit
um AMG Mercedes ooh Mercedes yeah
Mercedes is this is Mercedes you know
what AMG stands for
American made great
because Mercedes is an American no it's
German so the A and the m is the last
name of two German dudes and the g is
the hometown of the guy with the last
name that begins with an a according to
my two seconds of research and it's the
top of the line okay [__] uh like
they already have a sick ass German car
and then it's like you know but is this
monkey garage and they kick it up a
notch isn't there a car called The mg as
well yes my dad had one of those that's
not that's not the same company or same
no Factory or no whatever uh mg uh was a
was English is what it was and they had
these little two-seater race cars nice
cars yes they were when a lot of the
American soldiers uh got exposed to
European cars uh sports cars two seaters
and that type of [__] Italian stuff and
English stuff and German [__] when uh no
offense to German people German stuff
when uh they were when they were
fighting over
fighting over in Europe and um so when
they came back those cars sold over here
like uh EMG TD and the [__] triumphs
and all that [__] in the Italian stuff
um so anyways
these guys I don't know if they just
make the best [__] cars anyways hey
Bill just listen to your podcast when
you talked about how much you enjoyed
your test drive of the AMG wagon the
station wagon which you just uh yeah
yeah I know I know you love it but I'm
just I I [__] badass it's because I'm
totally with you on the sleeper wagons
being badass I just wanted to write you
to see if you've looked into the
Cadillac CTS V Wagon at all in my
opinion it looks meaner than the
Mercedes and would cost you tens of
thousands less those Cadillacs are mean
looking with that vertical brake light
that they have they just look [__]
angry I love them they loved Cadillacs
and he always looked badass driving them
they're just badass cars yeah I I
absolutely uh if I got a bunny mine uh
has one it's just a [__] great car
they're great you know I realized I'm a
sedan guy I really am I like I'm too
social media look at me
I gotta have people in the backseat if
you're gonna have a [__] two-door car
don't have a back seat that's so dumb
people
to be a station wagon I mean I'm not
like do you know it's funny there's
nothing wrong with station wagons but
they just I don't know they carry that
thing about them that makes it just feel
like
I don't know just like
not that there's anything wrong with
having a family car but like they're
just not sexy that's what it is a
station wagon is not sexy whether it's a
Mercedes or it's a Cadillac I just you
know what it is it's because you guys
all you guys know is nerds
you guys if you and everybody else who
trashes wagons if you knew anybody who
played in bands guitar players drummers
Surfers all these cool badass people
drive [__] yeah yeah because station
wagons because they're carrying like I
see a station wagon for a surfer that
makes sense the shape ones the boards
and stuff do you plan on putting
surfboards in a station wagon I play
drums I say and you can't put drums in
any other kind of car but a station
wagon right all those vans that bands
travel around them
anybody can take anybody station wagons
anybody all the baddest bands ever
I'm not saying they all did look anybody
can take a [__] like I just think to
look at a [__] like a Corvette or
something like that it's [__] awesome
like just it's for that thing to go fast
it's designed to go fast
I just when you I'm so sick at arguing
with this point when you look at a
station where you get everything that
everybody thinks about a station wagon
that's what makes it cool that the thing
then [__] blows you away off the
[__] line that's all I'm saying
that's all I'm saying I'm done talking
yeah all right firemen
oh I asked for some firemen to uh
to uh write in you know but some [__]
that they found in a fire and they
actually kept it oh really yeah they're
not gonna tell you what they kept why
this is all Anonymous ow are they big
bad Bill my father was a fireman for
over 20 years one morning he came home
and handed me a Ren and Stimpy shirt oh
my God that's funny because he knew I
liked me you idiot stab you idiot you
idiot don't deserve to live
um I didn't put it together right away
that he had taken it from a job
he couldn't even buy his kid a simple
red and Stimpy shirt he had a steal from
I'm sorry I mean he's still he thought I
was a lovely man I'm sorry I don't mean
to diss your dad but that's just funny
of all things to give your kid a t-shirt
from a fire and not like I feel like he
earned it he put his life on the line
a bike that was managed to be spared or
something like that but a t-shirt
that is kind of weak you know it smelled
like [__] soot
probably had like little holes in it
from Amber's landing on it there you go
kid who loves you
because I didn't put it I didn't put it
together right away he had taken it from
a job but when I did I felt so horrible
thinking that someone's entire life
disappeared in a fire and now I had one
of their only surviving possessions
I hadn't thought of that shirt a long
time until you brought that up on an
unrelated note check out the book meat
is for [__] by John Joseph uh you
always make comments that sound like you
could be persuaded to try a
vegetarianism
um I would if I could just get myself
into like learning how to cook it and I
just I bought like you know how to cook
it you know how to cook every vegetable
you know how to cook grains you know how
to cook beans and rice and all that kind
of stuff you know how to do it so you
know I'm a crabby old man I mean I know
what to do with the pork chop I don't
know what to do with [__] eggplant no
there's certain foods you would like to
cook more than others like you like to
make braised short ribs you like to make
pie you like to make pumpkin bread so
these are the things that you make yeah
I do it's not like you can't cook
lasagna
um I think this book might help you take
the take the final step the author is a
nut who has been singing for a great
punk band for the last 30 years but he's
in killer shape and breaks it down in
all sorts of conversation I'm all over
this
conversational English it's not boring
hippie dippy commune pamphlet it shows
all sorts of athletes and fighters who
are shredded without using any animal
products I've been a vegetarian for 23
years so it didn't convert me but it
served as a great source for rebuttals
when insecure meat eaters go after me
for eating rabbit food and say other
dumb things because my eating habits
remind them of how shitty their diet is
it's worth checking out love the podcast
keep up the great work go [__] yourself
P.S stop cutting yourself off short when
you talk drums music I sit through hours
of you talking Sports which I still find
entertaining but I don't give a [__]
about but every time you get nerdy about
drumming which I love you say oh this is
boring everyone and move on please stop
doing that I would rather hear you spend
a half hour talking about John Bonham's
right foot then some jerk off overpaid
Meatheads throwing arm oh my God amazing
I suspect that there are others who
agree with me yeah that's a that's a
solid Point yeah guys in station wagons
driving to the [__] gig who don't eat
meat
no I think vegetarianism is is cool
though there's some really I I would be
completely satisfied you know what I
love about if I ate a total vegetarian
meal I don't choose to because I like
meat but I wouldn't be mad if that's all
you know what's great about eating
vegetarian a healthy way of eating
vegetarian is you don't get you can eat
you don't get fat and then you don't
have to worry oh God I can still work it
out like me right now I gotta [__]
but there are some fat vegetarians
though yeah those are the ones who don't
read up on it they just stop eating meat
and they eat [__] chips yeah pasta
and bread right I'm a vegetarian I can
eat that it's like too which chin just
said that so
um
no I would like to do that like I would
like to try to uh
just as you get older it's harder and
harder to [__] stay in shape and I
just don't want to look like a [__]
you know you start getting that [__]
torso that like that cops usually find
floating in a lake you know oh my God
yeah all bloated
that's because it's been in a lake
yeah that's because you you know it's
because you're dead
it's cause you're dead in the bacteria
in your gut oh God it's already there
Nia all right all right the back when
you die someday the bacteria that's
gonna eat you up you're so morbid it's
fascinating no it isn't and it sits in
there your whole life no it's nature
it's what the [__] supposed to happen
what's ranges interest what's supposed
to happen to you okay the least [__]
jerk offs who get buried and you get
stuck it's [__] circles they get
buried don't blame them they're dead and
and they they get buried and they get
shoved in a drawer in the basement of a
church those people it's the biggest
[__] waste of stupid
your fertilizer does it put you in the
ground instead of one of those
mausoleums the whole [__] thing it's
a circle you just go okay
you're alive why do they decide to put
people in those instead of in the ground
because it's like fancier and you're
better than normal yeah the ground yeah
you can't be you can't beat warm food
you have to be like uh
nah man there's something cool about
just [__]
just being rotted just right away to God
dust boom over
get out of here beat it yeah just
[__] sitting there with your dumb
headstone
so people can come up to what Jack
Daniels and [__] put their arm around
him that's you man
he's not there she's not there they're
[__] they're they're in the air
you can stay at home and do that you're
right just like crazy philosophical
tonight
philosophical is stupid both I know one
of the other well all right
um
lying about medical school I've been
lying about medical school to my family
and friends for the last two years I
know
uh he's 23 this is understandable he's
proud 15 and lying about you know Jesus
all right all right fine fine Jesus can
you give can you give the kid a [__] at
23 in the like
if you saw how [__] introverted I was
at 23. you know
why compared to the Glorious social
butterfly that you were today Jesus you
were on fire
listen I like who I like okay I like
I don't like [__] you know I just
don't like those big parties you gotta
stand there do you [__] eyebrows up
oh yeah is that what you do you know
well it did rain yesterday yeah you're
not good at small talk is what it is
it's pointless and then in the party
conversation I gotta come up with some
sort of thing to just say and just when
they look and you feel the same thing
just be like dude
don't feel you don't have to talk to me
we don't have to do this that sounds
like a great way to make somebody feel
comfortable yeah no if they know you
know what I mean these [__] we don't
have to do this we can just sit here and
enjoy the quiet until our wives come
over and drag us back into that
and you just click your drinks it just
definitely worth between men that's so
funny yeah
I would love to I used to do a bit about
I used to talk about you on stage when
you come up everything okay like I
always end up drifting into a corner at
these parties you're the social
butterfly going around everybody [__]
loves you I'd just be standing in the
corner drinking a Miller right and then
you come over and just be like is
everything okay I just hear anything I
feel like you're avoiding the party yeah
it's like I am in the beginning when I
was getting to know you and then I
realized you know what a wildly you know
dazzling personality that you can be at
Social Gatherings and I just let you do
your own thing and then I do my thing
and then what happened you always say
that I abandon you at parties
no that was early early on that was
weird to me that I was just that you
just hey and you'd break off and I'd be
like what I'm used to someone being on
my hip and they would just be like and
it's a challenge so first it weirded me
out and then then I was like wait a
minute this is perfect yeah you go
around you go around the room and be
like oh look at you yeah
what is in this what is in this oh my
God this is hey Bill come on over and
try this I said I'm in the corner like
no no all set you find the one other guy
at the party that likes Sports and you
guys end up talking all night it's
perfect it really is perfect it's the
perfect I usually I you know what
nobody's feelings get hurt we have we
have very independent social lives I
think that's important you know
I [__]
I go over it I I find the room nobody's
in
I just stand there I know you always
want to sit down yes
what are we standing up for but you know
what I don't like this I don't like the
stand either anyway we have to get back
to the question watching all the [__]
couples competing with each other
yeah all the dumb [__] that then oh what
do you mean you see the [__] woman
jealous of her bag and then you see
they're talking to his eye and then he's
sitting there go oh God now I gotta buy
a [__] bag
gotta buy a [__] bag because Susie
Q's got the [__] yellow one
can I hate her she's so she's skinny
right she's skinny you know that's a
nightmare chick and then you drive home
you got to convince
the woman you're with that you didn't
want to [__] anybody there at the party
oh yeah she was too skinny for me yeah
she should have put she should have left
something to the imagination thank God
our tits were hanging out [__]
and and it was a great thing to look at
while I was in the middle of that awful
conversation another example of why
having independent social lives is so
great because I don't invite you to [__]
because I know that you're not gonna be
into it so I don't even invite you you
did forever I did and then I stopped and
I was like yeah do you want to go to
blah blah blah no and then you would
always go
[Laughter]
give me a [__] break you've died a
thousand deaths because I invited you to
parties because I want to spend time
with you oh just hang you up on that
cross it's so hard yeah the things that
you went to what the fact that they were
called parties is an absolute insult to
what standing around with doing all your
bonehead comedian friends while you
insult each other for three hours that's
like supposed to be something amazing
never called that a party
certainly not
it is not a problem what did I say when
you and uh Joe DeRosa and Keith Robinson
we're gonna have dinner and you're like
oh you can come to and I said who's
going
oh yeah yeah it was going like nope yeah
then you're smart then went to this
beautiful [__] great Steakhouse ate
this unbelievable food and all we did
was sit there and make fun of Keith's
[__] sweater and then the waitress
came over had the best insult because
Keith was defending the sweater and then
she comes over and we go what do you
Excuse Me Miss and she already knew that
we would jerk-offs and we just said what
do you think of when you look at Keith's
sweater and she goes Freddy Krueger oh
and it was and it was it was such a
Freddy Krueger it was that Thanksgiving
colored thick stripe [__] sweater I
was great and he had to just sit there
and take it and that that made my meal
and she said do you want dessert I said
no you just gave it to me sweetheart I'm
sorry
um all right so he says I've been lying
about my medical
school to my family and friends for the
last two years I'm 23. I have aspired to
be a doctor ever since moving to the
United States when I was 10.
I crushed it in high school without
really studying graduated graduated as
sorry I already go to salutarian and I
[__] graduated as salutarian I don't
know what that means is that number one
in the class two
Jesus Christ valedictorian is number one
oh salutatorian is number two what's
what's the bronze I don't know
um she's just the class president or
something they didn't Ascend that high
academically but socially they were
popular enough to get voted as president
I was in the supplemental draft
all right so I had an ego trip going
into college and decided to push myself
in order to get into the top tier
medical schools by junior year I was
double majoring working in a research
lab and teaching uh how do you say that
word recitation what the [__] is that a
recitation session of my own do you know
what that is I don't so how do you know
that's how you say it
why don't you sound it out like do I
have to like help you like a child in
school learning words sound out rest it
tasty look recitation what else would it
be I don't know I don't know what it is
and neither do you
how do you know it's not recitation
anyways uh on my own uh uh uh recitation
session of my own on top of volunteering
in the ER as an EMT during off hours wow
I'm gonna say this dude burned himself
out to make a long story short I
overextended myself my but by graduation
my GPA sank solo that no United States
medical schools would ever consider my
application I was too ashamed to admit
this to my family and friends who have
always considered me as smart as the
smart one of the bunch for two years
after graduation I've been lying about
working full-time and applying to
medical school but rarely but barely
missing the cut or at least you're
oh you've been lying that you have that
oh about working full-time and applying
to Middle School very well so that's
what's really going on you're working
full-time and you keep missing the cut
in reality I am working oh in reality oh
that is what you're doing sorry in
reality oh my God hey
it's the reason I'm a clown for a living
oh this is torture how long it's taking
you to get through this
in reality I am working part-time
secretly taking classes to improve my
GPA
and have never applied this lie has
gotten so elaborate that I have been
making application Size credit card
payments to a credit card my parents
don't know I own so if they review my
bank statements it actually looks like I
have been applying what the burden of
keeping the truth to myself and it's
gotten so bad that I'm actually starting
to feel a disconnect from my family and
friends first question should I come
clean or should I just keep up the LIE
until I get into medical school second
question is it even worth pursuing this
dream anymore by the time I improve my
GPA I'll be 25 plus four years of
medical school plus three years of
residency I'll be 32 by the time I have
my first day of work that's still pretty
young dude I would love to take your
advice to heart I think you're far more
insightful than give us no compliments
here oh he came out of it he goes I
think you're far more insightful than
you give yourself credit for but you're
still a balding Ginger go [__] yourself
gotta keep you honest over there all
right he's a good [__] um I would
definitely come clean because this is
[__] eating away at you and your
brain and it's making you you live in a
double life here I would definitely do
it and you if if it still really is your
dream who gives a [__] who gives a [__]
yeah who cares how long it takes but
something tells me that I didn't
congratulate regular regular College
until 25.
yeah that's true
um and it doesn't I don't know I get the
feeling that he actually doesn't want to
be a doctor anymore
what no I didn't see that what would you
I mean I don't know I mean I don't know
either what do you think
um because I just feel like
I don't know I just feel like he or she
is um probably he though I just feel
like the way it's written as a guy I
just feel like yeah maybe you got burned
out and really you don't maybe you don't
want to do it anymore is there a
possibility that there's other things
that you want to do but either way no
you shouldn't lie anymore because and
it's not so much about other people it's
like you were saying it's about you it's
how it's eating you up inside and making
you feel disconnected from your family
and friends that's not good like they
they love you you know I think it really
comes down to they don't want you to be
miserable hopefully this guy's
academically George Foreman
right before he fought up fought Ali
where he just never lost never got
knocked down
and then when Ali knocked him down he
said years later that he could have got
back up but he'd never been there before
and I think this dude was crushing it
without [__] trying because he was so
smart and then it got a little hard and
uh he's dealing with
um
like uh dealing with a couple of losses
you got to turn it around dude it's not
you're not even [__] 23 years old
dude that's way too young to pack in
look at this way
this is how I always looked at it all
right
you're 23 all right you're saying by the
time you get through all this [__]
you're going to be 32. what would you
rather be at 32 32 not a doctor or 32
just became a doctor if that's what you
want to do
all right because someday dude you're
going to look at 32 years of age and be
like Jesus I was a kid
I was a [__] kid I still had it all
ahead of me and you do
so stop being so hard on yourself come
clean because it seems like it's it's
you turn you're turning yourself into a
bit of a sociopath here
um yeah because in two years is a long
time and the fact that you're making
these payments yeah you like the credit
card and stuff that's a little much yeah
so what are you doing like buying flat
screen TVs to be like oh that's for this
and then yeah that's a little yeah
that's that's taking it too far I mean
it takes the TV and throws it over the
backyard French
yeah there's really no need to get this
elaborate with it you let's let's scale
back before you do anything and here's
something crazy as upset as your parents
get at some point you guys are all gonna
laugh at it you're all gonna laugh let
the [__] that my parents laugh at the
stuff that I [__] did
yeah I got arrested for drinking and
driving I've never seen my mother have a
more disappointed look on her face she
still rolls her eyes but when I tell the
story she laughs now she laughs they'll
get over it all right they'll get over
it okay but uh you know I just
you still want to be a doctor dude the
fact that you be a doctor at 32 would be
[__] amazing yeah of course like
becoming a doctor is [__] amazing
it's so hard if you want to do it if you
want to do it oh my God it is so hard
it's so hard you guys no because he's
saying what does he say I'm working
part-time I've been like I'm secretly
working part time
doctor to improve and have never applied
um
do you like working part-time though and
what are you working at because I I feel
like there's something else that he's
interested in doing okay
yeah like I know he wants he says he
wants to be a doctor and I don't doubt
that but I bet what if there's something
else that might be even more interesting
and
I don't know not make you turn into a
person that has to make up a second life
I don't know I don't know the way I read
it I don't think he ever had to I think
he just put too much pressure on himself
oh yeah that's true too I think his
parents will be fine with it and if
they're not then they're not your real
parents that's right they're not your
real name
you know they said if they don't agree
then you're not your real friends but
you are but your mental like emotional
well-being is is way more important than
uh medical school I feel like ultimately
right
uh I wasn't listening to you I was
already looking at the next question
you know what before I came in here I
was reading about adult ADHD because you
know I like to read it every couple
months and like make you take a quiz
just to confirm the facts bring it in
here in fact I'll take the quiz right
now have adult ADHD should I go get it
go get it I'll take it and I'll answer
the next one I'm gonna [__] destroy
this test
you know she's out of the room you know
I'm gonna destroy it I'm just gonna
[__] lie
never let the broad in your life psycho
[__] analyze you all right
whether you wanted or not they're
already gonna be running around in your
head you don't need to [__] open the
door you know what I'm saying
when you get a relationship with a woman
remember that Star Trek one where they
[__] tied those guys hands behind
their back and they stuck that worm in
their [__] helmets and put it on they
went in their ear
that's what I'm talking about all right
skating rink dear Billy Bruins you've
been talking a lot about your home
renovation but we never heard much about
the yard which leads me uh leads to my
suggestion of installing some ice in
your backyard
dude I live in Los Angeles
surprised me how few people have these
things going on regardless of whether or
not you could actually do it is that
something
you would want to have two out of the
four seasons of the Year PS maintain the
ice would be the hardest part thank you
oh dude are you kidding me I would love
to have a rink in my backyard
although would I want to go through
living in a place where I have to go
through Winters
I did that for 40 years I did my time
I bought enough ice scrapers in my life
I love the winter I like to visit it at
this point and um you know and all you
guys who say I'm a [__] now you show me
how it's done by staying back there in
the [__] goddamn winter
um anyways all right
that's the podcast for this week
everybody uh thank you for listening
we're waiting
um oh by the way by the way by the way I
finally got some Boston dates coming
your way
uh rumor has it that oh freckles
is coming to town sometime possibly
possibly in May
and I'm gonna do uh a run of dates at
the Wilbur Theater I'll let you know
I'll let you know definitely when uh
when that's going down and also I'm
going to be doing another bus tour
through the South
and we're not [__] around this time
we're gonna go to uh I wanna try to
avoid all major cities in the South I
want to go to I don't want to go to
Nashville I just was there I want to go
to Knoxville Memphis Shoe Fly North
Carolina oh mobile
I already got a theater I'm picking out
to go to Mississippi I've never done
stand up in Mississippi
um somebody showed me one and I want to
go to some cool venues some old theaters
that have some history somebody showed
me one in Shreveport Louisiana that both
Elvis and Johnny Cash played at it's
pretty big I don't know if I could fill
it but uh
that's what I'm that's what I'm looking
to do and then after I booked the tour
phase two is I want all you [__]
southern people to tell me where you eat
in that town and I won't [__] tell
anybody I won't blow up the spot you
just let me know where to go some mom
and pop [__] place do not tell me
about the Applebee's or the Cracker
Barrel or whatever the [__] I want to
know where the [__] you go
uh you know to eat okay that's the deal
now let me take this [__] test here
here we go
all right ready this is the whole thing
that I have to study the whole thing is
the whole thing is never rarely
sometimes often okay that's how you
answer
is that the title of it no that's how
you answer you already failed that
sounds like a [__] the name of a book
how often do you ever rarely see
something saving your attention while
doing something for work school hobby or
fun activity EG remaining focused during
lectures there's too many [__] things
hobby if I'm playing drums I haven't
even finished the questioning you're
already like because it's vague
are you gonna answer are you gonna do
this or not all right good I'll just
pretend you have like power over me how
often do you have difficulty sustaining
your attention while doing something for
work school a hobby or fun activity
never
if you already know the answers never
rarely sometimes often often
how often are you easily distracted by
external stimuli like something in your
environment or unrelated thoughts what
is that noise say it again
I was already thinking about the joke I
was in the middle of it I was going can
I imitate barbarina what are people
gonna get it oh my God I don't even need
to I don't even need to ask you often
how often are you easily distracted
you're not a doctor you're not a doctor
I'm not saying I'm a doctor who
psychcentral.com oh [__]
[__] forget it then whatever they say
I am how often do you avoid disliked or
are reluctant to engage in time I hate
people who spells like yes
I'm psyched and they spell it with an S
it's so gay
how often do you avoid
dislike or a reluctance
to engage I dare you embarrass me like
this on my own [__] podcast sustained
mental effort or thought
no I actually didn't hear the first part
of it oh my God oh my God it's like
three times
you cannot [__] pay attention to save
your [__] everything you read no
because it reminds me of all the [__]
exactly what ADHD
adhds you can't focus it doesn't mean it
reminds you other [__] Bill the like the
second question was how often are you
easily distracted by his external
stimuli like something in your
environment or unrelated thoughts that
was question number two bill
often
oh my God
how often do you have trouble listening
to someone even when they're speaking
directly to you
your mind is somewhere else often it's
not somewhere else they're not
interesting
look at their shoes screw you
you're saying I'm not interesting no
don't [__] do you make it all about
you wow I got a [__] disease over
here often
how often do you have difficulty or in
organizing a task or activity needed to
get done EG poor time management fails
to meet deadlines difficulty managing
sequential tasks
not one of those was good
what oh I thought I thought those are
what you said in the end with the
options I told you at the beginning that
it's never rarely sometimes or often
that's how you answer somewhere between
rarely and sometimes there's I get [__]
done I'm a successful [__] guy that's
true all right why don't we say
sometimes okay how's that
well you're not supposed to say and I
was supposed to say what do you mean we
well I apparently need to coach you
through this because you keep getting
distracted oh you are a Devil Woman how
often do you fail to give close
attention to details or make careless
mistakes in things such as school work
at work during other activities rarely
take my work seriously okay sat in that
[__] writer's room six seven eight
hours a day I didn't have to be there I
could have showed up like the douche hey
write me something I didn't I sat there
how often do you forget to do something
you do all the time such as missing an
appointment or paying a bill not all the
[__] time not paying a bill though
I pay bills yes you do yeah but the the
important [__] in here the important
[__] I'm [__] locked and loaded I'll
put sometimes all the dumb [__] how
often do you lose misplace or damage
something that's necessary in order to
get things done your phone
eyeglasses paperwork wallet keys Etc do
I lose it or damage it what do you mean
damage it throw it how often do you lose
misplace or damage either one
oh [__] talk yes how often do you
have trouble following through on
instructions or failing to finish
schoolwork chores or duties in the
workplace egusara task but quickly lose
focus and are easily sidetracked
sometimes but not that much I'm really
good with the work thing there yeah no I
I would agree with that obviously you
are there's no doubt that you are
successful so what is what is the end
game of this so then you find out I have
[__] ADHD [__] whatever and then
what I lose the argument about the
[__] closet downstairs how often are
you unable to play or engage in
leisurely activities quietly
how often are you unable to play or
engage in leisurely activities quietly
I mean cigar smoking's pretty quiet I
love doing that sometimes
rarely okay rarely
how often do you have difficulty waiting
your turn such as while waiting in line
but who the [__] wants to stand in line
let's go
no if I see a long line I just like I
just think about what is is it really
worth standing in line
[Laughter]
is this
you know imperative to my [__]
survival I don't need it I'm out often
how often do you feel like you're on the
go acting as if you're driven by a motor
EG you're unable to be or uncomfortable
being still for an extended period all
right all right I see where this is in a
restaurant or a meeting
I like going to restaurants bill at the
end of a meal right wow you are still
finishing dessert you literally have
your coat on and you have your credit
card out you're holding it on the table
like looking around I know because
that's because of the [__] small talk
throughout all of it
oh here's the story people tell a story
you know this one you know a story is
bombing if in the middle of it you have
to go
so then
the [__] isn't grabbing that coat
sometimes I'll put
how often do you leave your seat and how
often do you leave your seat in
situations when remaining seated is
expected depends on whether I'm being
entertained your place in the office or
workplace if I'm being entertained
sometimes okay yeah I have a hot [__]
yeah how often do you blurt out an
answer before a question has been
completed EG completed another person
sense or can't wait your turn in
conversation
to ant oh an answer like I know the
answer because that doesn't happen
because I really don't know the answer
how often do you blurt out an answer
never happens or a question Jeopardy
completed Jeopardy or Wheel of Fortune
that never happens that's just six
that's I'm gonna I'm putting often and
you know it's often can I put often
hey you do whatever you want this
[__] test isn't going to affect my
life in any way I don't know what your
point is how often do you feel Restless
like you want to get out and do
something
yeah like I get up and during the day
and I want to do something yeah I don't
want to lay around like a douche so yeah
often how often do you fidget with or
tap your hands or feet or swarming how
many more
that's the same [__] question over
and over and over again how often do you
fidget or tap or squirm in your seat
I don't know sometimes okay
how often do you find yourself Talking
excessively can I tap out um how often
do you find yourself Talking often
sometimes I'm running my mouth all the
[__] times other times I clam up like
when I'm at a party I don't walk in and
take it over I see everybody
talking about their [__] I'm just
like this is awful
I don't understand the corner I don't
say anything
okay sometimes how often do you
interrupt or intrude on others such as
butting into their conversation and
taking over what others are doing
well I was with it until the end taking
over it's a little [__] hard butting
in or taking over
yeah these this is all the same [__]
question over and over again
see a patient non-adhd person would be
able to take this quiz and like uh you
know what this is just I'm gonna put
something all right it's almost done uh
were several of the symptoms present uh
prior to age 12.
no you never felt this way as a little
boy okay no no I didn't all right the
[__] was I worried about do these
symptoms appear in at least two or more
settings at home and school
or home and work or whatever
uh yeah
all right your score is there's 20
questions
you scored a total of 42 based upon your
responses to this adult ADD ADH
screening quiz you have replied in a way
similar to people who have symptoms of
moderate to severe attention deficit
disorder moderate to severe that's a
severe that's pretty much the entire
gamut oh there you go psych.com
you might have it a little bit or severe
all of that mental torture do you see
why I tap out half the time symptoms
typically worsen in situations that
requires you just interrupted mention or
mental effort or that are boring
you know that was written by Boring
people that are tired of getting
interrupted by exciting people
like Bill Burr everybody
ah go [__] yourself
don't [__] see what you just did you
dragged me through my own [__] and then
they go but I love you hey just look at
this right here this is this is the guy
I worked with the other day Brad Carter
who right there you remember him right
look at this picture right there Reggie
Ledoux oh yeah yeah
he was awesome yeah I'm gonna post a
video he had he had he's got a video on
uh the internet says man plays guitar
while having brain surgery and it's him
what because they were they were him
I'll let him tell the [__] story I
already sound dumb enough as it is but
uh
[__] uh that's cool
amazing [__] actor funny as [__]
hell and like can be scary if he wants
to be he's I'm really looking out for
this guy to do big [__] man all right
that's the Monday Morning podcast
everybody good luck with your holiday
shopping and good luck if your [__]
wife comes in and goes hey you want to
take a test
[Music]
what's up everybody and welcome back to
the anything better podcast NFL Edition
sponsored by bet MGM this week we will
be previewing a week number
15 guys four more NFL weeks to go
as you guys can tell it is just me and
um our producer The Greek Freak Andrew
stemless Bill Burr
um unfortunately had something uh last
minute that he had to take care of uh so
that's stuff that uh you know happens
and we are here however the good news is
we have Bill's picks so we're gonna
Bill's picks are in
um I will do my picks Andrew will read
off Bill's picks so you will see that
and um we will get into what we did last
week the records that we did last week
our current records and where we're at
but first everybody but first we have to
talk about our great sponsor uh the BET
MGM the BET MGM uh uh sports book has
the best lines out there you guys know
we've been working them for two years
now uh they're always live and they're
always spot on please uh if you want to
bet responsibly there's no better place
uh to go than bet MGM and all you have
to do is download their app and use
bonus code Burr that's b-u-r-r very easy
bonus code Burr okay you'll see the
anything better at the uh way to do it
whatever once you click on there and you
use that and all you have to do is put a
minimum of ten dollars in and they will
match up to a thousand dollars of your
bets guys even if you lose they're gonna
match it doesn't get better than that so
you just go go to the App Store you
download uh and get the BET MGM app use
bonus code burn
you put in uh as little as 10 up to a
thousand bucks they will match it even
if you lose it does not get easier than
that bet responsibly and have fun but
use bet MGM the best lines out there now
uh
I'm not gonna say I talked [__] last
week about going three in one and
getting over the 500 Mark I will say
that I was happy that I was three and
one and I finally got over the 500 Mark
considering that I was eight games back
a few weeks ago well you could talk a
little [__] you earned it Hey listen man
I had to fight I had to climb myself out
of a hole
um but this week I went one in three
which makes me
27 28 and one keeping me a half game
back but look I'm still right there I'll
take it bill went uh two and two uh
bringing him to 24
28 and four which I mean which I think
just brings him two games back making
him only a game and a half back of me so
we are right there guys we are in
Striking Distance at uh at week 15.
uh I believe I go first this week
and then Andrew will read off Bill's
picks
um and here's the deal I do not know as
we speak I do not know Bill's picks so
Andrew and I'll do some editing if
there's a match but as I'm talking now I
do not know Bill's picks uh it is an odd
week which means yours truly goes first
so here uh here we go with week 15 picks
oh Andrew I don't know dude I looked at
these the one thing I will say is
there's some low lines as low as minus
one and then you got some lines that are
you know you got a seven you got a nine
and then you got the fours and the yeah
you got a 14. we got a 14 in there yeah
yeah Chiefs
you have 14 in in Houston I mean they're
one in 15 but at this point they're
getting the first round pick are they
gonna put up a fight like they did the
Cowboys last week here's the thing I
think that fight was a battle of Texas a
little bit yeah that was all Texas that
was like Texas Pride
but now I think the Titans are like
let's get that number one pick in the
draft all right let's let's not slip and
win a game here to go down in the draft
they might want that that whoever that
number one guy is they want
um so that's a game that's a game but
I'm gonna do something here
I'm gonna do something I think they're
gonna
look
I took the charges last week I bet on
the charges last week a lot of people
thought that that was crazy I thought it
was crazy and I was wrong I suppose I
watched that game I couldn't I couldn't
believe it
too I gave you [__] for it yeah a lot of
people thought that the the Dolphins
were gonna go in there you know two
ahead no two I had no points in fantasy
no yards it's like two for nine passing
and um the charges looked like their
defense was ready and they looked really
different with their wide receiver Mike
Williams back
along with Keenan Allen back
um hey your boy Keenan Allen you played
golf with him at that ATC addict didn't
he were you there for that that wasn't
me no no that was uh Bill and uh
bertolina but I will say that Justin
Herbert looks really good I think this
is the time to come into your own and
really go to another level
um I'm gonna take the Chargers
minus two and a half at home against the
flailing Tennessee Titans I think the
Chargers have have finally gotten
healthy I also think Justin Herbert's
ribs are fully healed and he's got his
weapons back defense look good I'll go
Chargers minus two and a half give me
Bill's first pick here we go
all right uh I'll have to say the wrong
quarterback's name I'll cut there all
right uh okay uh for Bill's first pick
he took the San Francisco 49ers giving
three tonight
Thursday night against the Seahawks uh
bill and his exact words is done with
the Seahawks he took took Sneaky Pete
too many times he said he's all done so
San Fran minus three yeah and you know
something man I I was you know
I was wrong about the Niners just
because I thought with Garoppolo out and
this new kid I thought look you're gonna
get a new kid in there a young kid in
there usually that's good for two picks
and making bad decisions this kid went
in there and um looked really really
good I like that pick so all right
Bill's got the Niners now
my second pick
of this week 15 I am going to take oof
that's a tough one
that's a tough one I don't think I know
this is nuts I'm gonna take
the Carolina Panthers dude I think this
is the first time I've taken them all
year
they are right there now with Sam
darnold playing well in the thick of
things
Pittsburgh's all over the map Pittsburgh
wins two weeks you think they're coming
then they lose Carolina has kind of now
looks like they've right at the ship a
little bit even though they got rid of
Baker Mayfield they got rid of McCaffrey
and it's minus three and they're at home
and I don't know who the Steelers are so
I'm sorry Steeler fans I usually like to
ride with you guys especially being a
Giants fan it's kind of all in the same
family but I gotta take the the Panthers
uh buy a field goal at home
it's a it's a good pick that's almost a
that's almost a coin toss the Steelers
are that much better they're just a
little bit better than minus one on that
the Steelers are just a team that yeah I
just don't know who they are dude and
whenever it comes down to that this late
here's what here's what I'll say in the
NFL and and listen the listeners can
agree or not but I know a lot of things
change a lot of things are different
there are still some things that happen
that you're like how could that happen
because we don't even know who the Tampa
Bay Bucks are still we don't know who a
lot of these teams are still I you know
the Patriots seem like every you know
what even bill was saying something this
is a type of year and Andrew you'll
agree with this
this is a year Bill said it's one of the
weirdest years and I agree with them
this is a year where it's like you feel
like you know something and you're like
oh this is what it is I'm seeing it and
then it's literally you just can't you
just can't choose yeah and and most
gambling Seasons feel like that because
you know what I mean it's like that's
you know anything over 500 is is a
winning you know season so it's like
half this half of the games are going to
feel like jeez I don't know what's going
on here but uh it is a very common
excuse but I'm gonna agree with you this
is a really weird year
um I've even had that conversation with
the people and other
uh you know big Sports gamblers uh
who've said like yeah it's it's an
excuse that people use every year but
for some reason this is the year we've
had so many coin toss games like this
where it's like who knows
injuries all over the place man yeah
excuse everybody Paul is right this is a
weird year well you know another thing
too is like look what happened uh right
away Kyler Murray gets hurt you know
Kyler Murray gets hurt for the Cardinals
in the first three plays of the game and
that changes you know so I mean that can
be with anything though but I I just
think I like to stick now with teams
that I kind of know week 15 I think I
know and then um and that leads us to
Bill's next pick
yes that leads us to Bill's next Pig I'm
sorry so I took the uh the Panthers okay
go ahead yeah you took the Panthers uh
and and bill is going with the Vikings
minus four
that's a great pick [__] I like that
picture yeah it's a good one because
that's a great one
look the Vikings need to show now like
now is the time especially if they're
gonna really try to compete with the
Eagles in the NFC and some of these
bigger teams I mean I know they still
have a great record but they they've got
to beat the Colts at home I mean there's
there's really no excuse and minus four
is kind of I wouldn't be shocked I
wouldn't be shocked if that if that
moved by Sunday if that moved to five
about five or six and a half or
something because
minus four I mean listen
I mean what are the Cults to to the
Vikings right now I don't know I don't
know hey I thought the Dolphins were
gonna win so you know who am I
who am I
um
I'm gonna this is probably maybe one of
the dumbest picks I'll make all year and
I know I shouldn't be gambling literally
like this
um when I'm this close to 500 I have a
game out
I'm gonna take the Kansas City Chiefs
minus 14. okay you gotta have fun Paul
you gotta I I think that the fact that
the Texans put up a fight with the
Cowboys for a while and looked like they
were going to win that game and still
lost
I think it's time that the Texans put
their hands up and say let's go get that
number one pick I think that the Chiefs
I think the Chiefs know they have this
is a team that they have to beat if they
want a first round buy I think they go
in there and they just whoop their ass
so I will take the Chiefs by two
touchdowns uh they should win that game
by 20.
I like it I like it you're writing these
down or am I uh say it again we're
writing these down oh yeah yeah
um yeah no I like that pick I like that
I like attacking a good 14 point spread
hey man it's definitely stupid if the if
the Texans score first I'm down 21
points what are you gonna do that's
that's a good way of putting it too huh
yeah yeah
um for Bill's third pick uh he has uh he
he picked against the Eagles in the past
and and he said he was tired of tired of
losing that game so he went with the
Eagles
-9
yeah I was just I like that one too I
like that I was just looking at that
I mean the bears plus nine at home it's
not impossible there there's I would say
half the teams in the league we've said
are like any given week teams right I
mean that's just what it is but uh the
Eagles gotta win that game by by a few
they they need the momentum
you know yeah they finish up the season
so
equals minus nine
um
all right dude this is I I don't know
why I do this to myself
I don't know why I do this to myself
I'm gonna do it dude I'm gonna take the
Tampa Bay Buccaneers at home getting
three and a half against the Bengals
something tells me Bill took the Bengals
uh did did he oh no okay
um I'm gonna take because this is it
this is you know this is the season for
the bucks as far as I'm concerned they
just got embarrassed last week I mean
they got embarrassed to the point I
think at one point it was 35 nothing or
35 to 7. uh Brady had a look on his face
which I haven't seen in a while they are
at home and I like the reason why I'm
taking this is I'm not necessarily even
thinking the Bucks are gonna win this
I'm taking this bet or I'm taking this
pick guys because of the 0.5 the half a
point I'm taking this bet because I like
the three and a half okay I think that
it could be a really close game down to
a field goal Half Point gives me the
advantage so I'm gonna take them getting
a half point if this was like two and a
half I don't know if I'd be touching
this game three and a half I'm Gonna
Take It yeah that's not a bad pick I
mean the Bucks are gonna stay and
they're they're receiving core is
obviously not what it was at the opening
of the Season here but in the past few
weeks well the exceptional last week
they showed a little life Leonard
fournette still
still hitting the you know hitting yeah
because I mean he you know he's not
fully healthy so you're not getting 150
yards out of him but but he's he's still
there for the place yeah and what I
found with this team though is without
Gronkowski opening things up he just
doesn't have a nice rhythm with certain
receivers yeah Mike Evans is a guy he
used to always hit a Chris Godwin is
like hit or miss I think Gronk being
there when Gronk was there and that fear
and thought you know he's just like a
security blanket yeah yeah because you
have to double team him up the middle
you can't you can't go single coverage
up the middle because he'll pull the
ball right down over your head like like
the Giants in the last 30 seconds of the
Super Bowl but uh yeah I mean he'll pull
that ball right down and uh yeah so
that's that I I'm with you there but
you're right bucks plus three
uh Buck oh wait is it's plus three times
right three and a half three and a half
yeah plus three and a half yeah sorry
plus three and a half yeah [__] so I'm
gonna take the bucks plus three and a
half would be my that's my fourth that's
your fourth that's my fourth so wait so
I have just to be sure here because
Chargers mine is two and a half Panthers
minus three Chiefs minus Fourteen and
the bucks plus three and a half a lot of
dogs this week I like it or not dogs a
lot of favorites yeah
so now bill has one more Yep for Bill's
final pick
uh bill went with the New England
Patriots okay our New England Patriots
uh minus
uh minus one
in in Vegas
okay
yeah what do you think about that I'm
not saying it's a bad paper what do you
think about that what are the what are
the Raiders going to do what are the
writers gonna do
the Raiders are the Raiders are what we
were talking about before the Raiders
are one of those teams where I just
don't know I want you know like I I'm
like oh they did two in a row three in a
row the building feels good everybody's
like oh they did it they're gonna make a
run and then and then they just I just
don't know I don't know if the coach has
it in them dude and by the way this is
McDaniel Josh McDaniel going against
Belichick who he worked with for ever so
just Josh McDaniel going against Matt
Patricia as well if you think about that
in a sense yeah but it's being up on
Matt Patricia just because it's a sound
bite but like everybody can't be wrong
about the play calling like everybody
can't be wrong and I and and I've we
talked about I don't know if you
remember two seasons ago last season uh
we we had done uh Crossover with uh Sean
Green in the sports gambling podcast and
I remember that was one of the first
times really hearing about Matt Patricia
especially when he was with Detroit as
far as really just not not being able to
like lock into you know the proper play
calling offensive Rhythm so I don't know
I I actually
I hate to say it but it's gonna be a
tough one I I don't know it's gonna be a
tough one for the bats I don't know um
all right so
there we go so you got uh my pick you
got bills last pick is the Patriots
minus one look like we said like we were
just saying I like that against the
Raiders because I really think you want
to talk about a coin toss it's like who
who's showing up but I guess Plus what's
that Pat's place he's getting one okay
Pat's Pats are plus one on the road I
think it's a coin toss I you know you
don't know you don't know what you're
getting but I do think you the the
better Coach on the road you got a
better Coach clearly I think you gotta
you know I think you got a team that
just came off a nice win they're feeling
good they're still in it they're still
in it in their division so there you go
um now guys okay now we got to talk
about the Monday night special again I
mean it feels like it feels like I'm in
an AAA meeting and I just keep having
relapses and we just have to tell you
guys hey man sorry it happened again
um we right when you think it's like oh
all you need is a touchdown pass from
the started quarterback I mean that
happens every Prime Time game right and
then like no pass it's just like it's
coming down to the end but this week
bed MGM has uh released some fun bets
for the uh Monday night special out of
respect for Bill not being here I'm not
even gonna sing bills Monday night
special making money for you I'm not
gonna do that I'm gonna make you guys
miss that okay and maybe
could be Superstition Here Andrew but
maybe Bill not singing it this week will
be the the thing that gets us you know
and then once we get it then we get them
back and we start rolling who knows am I
grasping at straws absolutely you gotta
what else look we got we're a week 15.
we got to start making we got to start
making some money so we have some fun
prop bets that we can throw into this
Monday night special which we are going
to do and I believe this Monday night it
is the um
dude the Los Angeles Rams coming off
that like Miracle like Baker Mayfield is
with the organization for 48 hours he's
learning the plays on the airplane with
the coach they're down 16-3 the whole
game to the Raiders I believe he has the
Raiders they're down the whole game and
you're like oh and then Baker Mayfield
has two miraculous drives one he throws
a touchdown pass to win a game with like
eight seconds nine seconds left and they
win the game by one 17-16 and his Baker
is definitely
um is definitely what he's
he's quarterbacking this week for the
Rams
yeah yeah okay sure I mean I I that's
the the last I heard this yesterday but
I mean I know I mean who else
yeah well he's like the third yeah okay
that's okay so the Monday night game
this week is the Los Angeles Rams at
Lambeau Field at the Green Bay Packers
and the Packers are seven point
favorites
so the Rams are getting seven now I
think the Rams stink but the Packers
also stink what do you think this game
out right if you just had to look forget
about forget about everything else who's
gonna win this game are the Rams gonna
beat the Packers in Lambo
so money line wise
like if you're not talking spread I
think the Packers win
if you're not talking spread I think the
Packers win the seven point scares me
for sure especially with baker having a
little bit of what do you want to call
it Moxie or Baker's got a little bit of
you know kids coming off of like he's
got a little bit of Swag the kit and
there's two things about that though
with Bakers number one it's still Baker
Mayfield like that was an impressive
game last week I watched the game it was
it was really great it is still Baker
Mayfield and it's still the Rams
and they also were down that hole like
you said they were down the whole game
but here's the thing the Wonder is this
like was that a fourth quarter the
Raiders just didn't have it anymore they
gave up they let off the gas whatever
you know who knows I think it was more
of a I think this is me personally I
think it was more of a Raiders [__] up
than it was of a rams and look I saw
bacon I'll give you that it's close look
here's the deal dude and I'm not this is
I like Baker Mayfield I like [__]
talking a little bit or just I like a
swag I like them but I saw him live this
year I saw him live this year right in
front of me and when the Giants
pressured him he just doesn't make the
big and I know this is a weird thing to
say because he did make a big throw to
beat the Raiders at the end of that game
but through the course of a game when
he's on his feet he I don't see him make
like those running you know dark passes
that Aaron Rodgers makes
um they don't have Cooper cup you know I
know they're feeling good about what
happened last week but it's the seven
points can we do a money line bet can we
do just uh yeah let's do moneyline okay
so I I think if we do moneyline for the
Monday night special I say Packers
I say packages you'd like to pack gun to
your head what do you think Packers
like to win Packers It's gotta be I
gotta pick the Packers I I just I I
haven't had any faith in the Rams all
year and if if I take last week's
15 minutes out of the you know the last
15 minutes that came out of the equation
I'm not even having this like I'm not
even like going back and forth we're not
even having a conversation yeah that's
exactly what the front doesn't mean I
like that kind of faith and Aaron and
Aaron Rodgers and the Packers right now
either
um but but I'm I would say Packers money
line feels
feels pretty and we got a really good
like this one this one I like okay so
this is what I think we're gonna take
the Packers money line okay we are gonna
take Aaron Rodgers to throw one because
he's not one to run in really ever and
uh throw two if you want since we didn't
since we did moneyline and the odds are
a little we say a little pays a little
less than going against the spread if
you think and Paul let me ask you a
question does Aaron Rodgers throw two
touchdowns
thank you
greeting Paul you want to get greedy you
know what let's get our first win some
money guys let's have a little fun with
this and here's the deal you don't have
to take our whole Monday night special
you can take
yeah yeah you could like even if you
like mine and Andrew's reasoning for
Packers money line and you just have to
Annie up a little more that could be
what you're gonna do but here's what
we're gonna do we're gonna have a little
fun with this okay we're gonna do this
is gonna be a fun one it's probably
gonna be the most fun one of the year
we're gonna do Packers money line Rogers
to throw two and we have a prop bet for
you guys Baker Mayfield to rush right
can we do that
Baker Mayfield to rush over seven yards
right
okay that means Baker Mayfield needs to
scramble for seven yards usually that
happens with one scramble it should
happen the first time he runs the ball
he should clear seven yards but I think
he's gonna get seven yards for the game
because it's definitely gonna be
pressure from the Packers and I think
that he's gonna at least have to
scramble and get up some yards so
um
you want a fourth one in there
I don't know I think let's I I would say
with the two touchdowns two touchdowns I
know I know pushing if it wasn't the two
touchdowns I would say let's do it
because it'll pay but I still think we
have a nice money bet here so you get
all that has to happen is Packers gotta
win the game Aaron Rodgers throws two
okay which Aaron Rodgers could throw two
even if they're not gonna win the game
so I like that and then you get Baker
Mayfield to rush for more than seven
yards so if Baker Mayfield rushes for
eight yards in this football game that
that'll be a hit if the Packers win and
Rogers throws too I know it's a lot of
things to happen it's the most fun one
we've had
I know Bill would be thrilled with this
one wish he was here to talk about it
but we will definitely talk about it
next week but there you go that's the
Monday night special yeah Paul said if
you want to build your own bet just
download the app or go to the website
sign up you can build your own bet you
can see what the odds are it's a lot of
other good stuff uh AJ Dylan over under
40 40 rushing yards I saw that one yeah
we had to pick a fourth I'd go over on
that one so yeah guys if you don't yeah
that actually to reiterate what Andrew
just said that's true it's like if you
only like one thing we just said like
like I said if you like the money line
take the Packers on the money line but
then you can hit
who's gonna get the first touchdown of
the game like that's what the the BET
MGM app is giving you who's gonna hit
the first touchdown of the game who's
gonna have multiple touchdowns how many
they even give odds of like if AJ
Dylan's gonna have two or three
touchdowns Aaron Rodgers how many yards
he's going to pass for you could go to
all of those prop bets you can build
your own bet
um and then that'll take me right to the
to the Segway there go to the betmgm app
download it use bonus code Burr b-u-r-r
and uh put in as little as 10 bucks they
will match up to a thousand even if you
lose you just gotta put in the bonus
code bird and
um there you go uh enjoy it
click on and if you want to ride with us
when you go to the app you will see an
icon on the app that says Monday night
special anything better you'll see mine
in Bill's picture you'll see the logo of
our podcast you click on that and it'll
give you the choices to bet on the
parlay
um yeah I am a half a game back of 500
right now and Bill I believe is two
games yeah because he has four ties I
mean only Bill would have four ties
um which is basic is basically two games
so yeah he's two games back of 500 and
I'm a half a game back so there you go
man we're uh going into week 15. oh
Andrew I don't know that 14 points to
Chiefs I hope I hope that doesn't bite
me I hope that that's what I get well
they're gonna win by 65 don't you worry
Ellie by the way you know what's funny
is you can go to a bet I saw one of
these bad things and by the way guys we
really want to let you know because I
know some people talking oh yeah you
guys talk about MGM a lot yeah well bet
responsibly you know bet responsibly
we're we're doing this with fun like
this is not you know nobody's putting
their college you know their kids
college on that bet responsibly but they
do give a lot of fun stuff like there's
one that's like you can go in I did this
I put like 50 bucks on like if a team's
gonna win by 40 or more and your odds
fly up
you know like I'll tell you guys
something we'll go into uh we'll do a
little overtime like the fans like I got
a few minutes here but um I did
something fun on the on the app and uh
um Morocco played in the World Cup
against France
and if you took Morocco to win if you
took Morocco to win it paid pretty good
so I put I put uh I put 150 on Morocco
to win and I would have won a thousand
and of course they didn't but hey hey
yeah because the thing is you can go I
like those bets where you go super low
risk and Incredibly High reward oh dude
we we've talked about this I uh this
year been very busy you know uh just
with the football league with all this
stuff so I haven't been uh gambling like
like I usually do but my go-to is gonna
be like you know 5 to 18 bet parlay so
uh I'll you know I would put five five
dollars down pick five to eight teams
sometimes as much as up to up to ten in
fact my biggest hit was I picked five
games against the spread and the over
under I put down seven dollars and I won
4 200 and that was that was in 2013.
uh
and I find that if you're if you're just
chasing three games at like a hundred
bucks a pop you know four games hundred
bucks pop every week
you know you can you can start bleeding
and and you're looking you gotta hit you
know three of those to make money too
depending on whatever it is but if you
just get in there and you say you know
what I'm gonna throw 30 bucks down this
week you can have six different five
dollar bets across you can say hey you
know what on this parlay I've got these
five teams but I'm not sure about the
Bengals this week so I'm gonna do the
exact same parlay again only I'm gonna
switch out the Bangles so that way you
can kind of feel like all right like
this one could go either way but either
way five bucks you know thirty dollars
with the chance to win a few hundred you
hit one in the first few weeks you can
play for the rest of the year so that's
that's always been my take I've never
been one of these I'm gonna put 500 on
the Patriots so I only put 500 in the
Patriots no like unless unless you have
a really really really like if you're in
your heart you loved the game all week
and you're like I I'm willing to lose
the money because I just don't think I'm
going to then do that but yeah I like
what you're saying I like if you see a
few games that you like or and you could
put a little bit down to get a big pop
man it's like
um yeah I'm gonna like look it's just
fun man it's just fun if you can do it
responsibly you know of course of course
yeah yeah you're not gonna yeah you
can't believe that you know I gotta feel
it about let's go three grand like I
know guys like that it's just like whoa
you know
um it's the same reason you can't say
like all right we're about to drive home
let me funnel three beers real quick you
know it doesn't matter what you're doing
you gotta take it each you know what I
mean you gotta take it easy when people
say like oh gambling this that's just
like you know people listen to hours
people talking about dumb drunk things
it all falls under don't be an idiot you
know what I mean don't be an idiot you
know don't be an idiot now you should
have been I was an idiot I was an idiot
in college I funneled I hate Paul hey
Paul you know it takes one to know one
of the dumbest things I did in college
was I funneled just pure absolute vodka
and they put a scoop of they put a scoop
of like iced tea powder in it or
whatever and I I just [__] and I dude I
remember just sitting on the couch being
so and I'm like you could die you could
die you could get your stomach pumped
like I have children and I'm going like
that was the dumbest thing I did to try
to either I don't know like let's get so
hammered instantly so I don't even have
to go through the process of it and it
was so dumb so don't funnel your money
away
don't do that version because you think
that the Cardinals are going to cover
um
by the way let me just I just want to
say this for the show because I'm sure
the listeners know this already but this
got me really kind of this is really
cool guys
the NFL schedule
okay for Christmas Eve and Christmas is
amazing it's like dude it is like
because normally I remember Christmas
Eve there'd be like a couple games
Christmas day they'll be no no Christmas
Eve and Christmas Day fall on Saturday
and Sunday it's basically Thanksgiving
on steroids with like more games more
it's amazing so and we're gonna get into
those games obviously next week but um
here's what I want to have happen and
I'll tell you guys this I know me and
Bill have a friendly little Jimmy the
Greek contest but here's what I want to
have happen I want to have happen after
and I don't know we're gonna we're gonna
fight and try and look I'm happy that
we're standing here where we are
going into week 15 where the numbers are
based on what this year has been and the
Packers owe me three games because if I
would have laid off them it would be a
different story but I'm going to tell
you this is what I want after me and
Bill both beaten the book by four uh
four plus games last year okay I was
four and a half bill was four that means
me and Bill beat the Vegas book last
year by eight and a half games I was
four and a half a bill was four all we
want to do this year is if we both do it
again after the craziness of this year
or be right around 500 we will take it
but we want to go over so it starts now
okay and uh I will be cursing myself on
the next show if that Chiefs thing bites
me if the Texans start off like 19-3
I'll be sick but um there you have it
guys there you have it so get the app
download the you know the put the bonus
code in down the app there you go Burr
and and uh and have fun minimum up to
ten dollars want to thank bed mg I want
to thank Andrew Thurman Greek freak out
there I know he's actually uh on my
Coast he's on the east coast East Coast
it'll be home for the holidays
Beverly Hills kid look you could take
the Beverly Hills out of the kit
um what's what's Beverly Hills East you
know you can say I'm there Matt and Drew
the Beverly Hills kid is uh is on the
East Coast here uh he's a Patriots fan
who would have thunk it and as always
disclaimer there's disclaimers at the
end of every episode The Beverly Hills
kid does not really live in Beverly
Hills so
I'm right across the line you know maybe
one day maybe one day I mean look it's
close enough to me for me you know you
know what's funny is I always say that
the the the street that I'm on crosses
right over into Beverly Hills it's the
same same with street right but if you
look at Beverly Hills it looks just a
little wider because they got palm trees
you know it's like
yeah like the beginning of Beverly Hills
Cop yeah oh yeah that's that's every day
I'm yeah every day every day that's just
going Patti LaBelle's just going through
my head every day oh it's so great it's
so great all right well enjoy your week
everybody enjoy your uh shopping we'll
see you uh we'll see you next week I'll
talk to you soon and remember guys Tibet
you got to be 21 years of age or older
to wager in Arizona Colorado DC Iowa
Indiana Kansas Michigan Mississippi New
Jersey New York Nevada Pennsylvania 10
Tennessee
Virginia West Virginia or Wyoming only
new customer offer paid in free bets
visit betmgm.com for terms and
conditions uh excludes Michigan
disassociated persons uh please gamble
responsibly gambling problem call 1-800
next step for Arizona call
1-800-522-4700 for Colorado DC Nevada
Wyoming West Virginia
1-800-270-7117 for confidential help
Michigan
1-800 Gambler in Indiana New Jersey
Pennsylvania and West Virginia
1-800 bets off in Iowa call or text the
Tennessee Red Line
800-889-9789 in Tennessee or call
1-88-77-9696 for Mississippi sports
betting is void in Georgia Hawaii Ohio
and Utah and other states were
prohibited
promotional offers not available in
Nevada
[Applause]
[Music]